programming throwdown episode 68 soft skills with simple programmer take it away jason hey everyone this is a super cool episode. People might remember, you know, when I said what was my favorite book a while ago, it was not, you know, the awesome Ballstead book on statistics or things like that or the AI book. It's actually Negotiating for Dummies. That's the book that's really had the biggest impact on my life. And so these sort of things are extremely important. And I'm really excited that we could dedicate kind of a whole show to all the other aspects beyond just, you know the really important kind of career skills and really personal skills that can help kind of push people forward. And to do that, we have John Sonmez, who is the founder of Simple Programmer, which is a site where he talks all about this and he kind of indulges us in his expert information. So thanks for coming on the show, John. Yeah, thanks for having me, guys. I'm glad to be here and throw down.
Programming Throwdown 第68期：Simple Programmer 的软技能。Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好，这一期节目非常酷。大家可能还记得，前阵子我提到我最喜欢的书时，并不是那本关于统计学的牛书，也不是人工智能方面的书，而是《谈判傻瓜书》（Negotiating for Dummies）。那本书对我的人生影响最大。所以这类事情极其重要。我很高兴我们能专门用一整期节目来探讨除了那些非常重要的职业技能之外，还有哪些个人技能可以帮助人们不断进步。为了实现这一点，我们请到了 Simple Programmer 的创始人 John Sonmez，他会在这个网站上分享所有相关内容，并向我们传授他的专业知识。感谢你来到节目，John。好的，谢谢你们邀请我。很高兴能来到这里参加 Throwdown。
All right. Sounds good. So why don't you tell us, you know, what is Simple Programmer? You know, why did you why did you kind of start that and where did that come from? Sure. So what it is now is much different than what it was then. And the why I started it has changed into the purpose of it now. So to go back in time, I started it really out of two main motives. One was just because it was a passive aggressive way where I was at to get people to listen to me. Because if someone reads something on the internet, it has a lot more clout, even if you just publish it yourself rather than me saying it. And plus, you get to finish your sentences and paragraphs. So I was working on a scrum team and they were doing some things wrong and I just thought, okay, I could just blog about kind of this stuff and my manager and my coworkers will read this.
好的，听起来不错。那么，你能告诉我们什么是 Simple Programmer 吗？你当初为什么会创办它，它的初衷是什么？当然。它现在的样子和当初大不相同，我创办它的初衷也已经演变成了它现在的使命。回溯过去，我创办它主要有两个动机。一个是把它当作一种被动攻击的方式，让我所在的地方的人能听我说话。因为如果有人在网上读到某些东西，即使是你自己发布的，也比我亲口说出来更有分量。而且，你还能完整地表达你的句子和段落。当时我在一个 Scrum 团队工作，他们做了一些错误的事情，我就想，好吧，我可以写博客来谈谈这些事，我的经理和同事们就会读到。
And they did and it did have a good effect. So that was sort of one of the complex and making it more complex. Or taking the simple and pretending like it's complex. Because it gives you, I don't know, it's an ego boost. It makes you feel like you're more valuable than you are. And I was like, no, no, this is wrong. Because we should really be telling people that programming is simple. And we should be explaining things and making things simpler rather than more complicated because at its at its heart i still firmly believe this there's
他们确实读了，而且效果不错。所以这是一种复杂化，或者说把简单的事情假装得很复杂。因为这能给你带来某种自我满足感，让你觉得自己比实际更有价值。我当时就想，不，不，这是不对的。因为我们应该告诉人们编程其实很简单。我们应该解释清楚，让事情变得更简单，而不是更复杂，因为在内心深处，我依然坚信这一点，那就是
nothing really hard there's there's there's things that are that in in conglomeration are hard but when you break things apart to the smallest pieces they're usually pretty simple right i mean you know i know i'm saying that with an extreme viewpoint, but in general, that's the case, especially in our field. So, yeah, I was sorry. I was talking to somebody today at lunch and there's someone who actually they used to work with me at a different company and they just came to my current company. And both of us kind of had the same experience where when we left, we thought I mean, we left on good terms and we thought, i'm have to write all this documentation there's so many things i know after you know x years and the reality is you leave and the company just keeps going as if you weren't even there right i mean i mean it it turns out that that uh when you get in in the middle of what you're doing it can
其实没有什么真正困难的事情。有些事情组合在一起确实很难，但当你把它们拆解成最小的部分时，它们通常都很简单，对吧？我是说，我知道我的观点比较极端，但总的来说，情况确实如此，尤其是在我们这个领域。所以，是的，抱歉。我今天午餐时和某人聊天，那个人以前在另一家公司和我一起工作，他刚来到我现在的公司。我们俩都有同样的经历：离开时，我们以为——我们是友好离职的——我们以为我得写下所有的文档，毕竟我工作了这么多年，知道那么多事情。但现实是，你离开了，公司照样运转，就像你从没存在过一样，对吧？我的意思是，当你身处其中时，它可能
seem like you know the it could seem like impossible for other people to sort of jump in. But the reality is that if you've kind of, uh, made things sort of, as you said, simple and kind of broken things down and written some documentation, um, you know, you've set up a nice path for the people who come kind of after you. Exactly. Yep. I, I totally agree. it's funny how people have that that guilt when they leave a company like they're gonna it's trust me it's not gonna it's not gonna crash into the ground yeah but um but but yeah so that's where i started out and so my blog was i mean i didn't know what i was doing right i just just created this blog just wanted to get some of this
看起来好像别人根本无法接手。但现实是，如果你像你所说的那样，把事情变得简单，把它们拆解开来，并写了一些文档，那么你就为后来者铺平了道路。没错。是的，我完全同意。人们离开公司时那种负罪感真是有趣，好像公司会因此倒闭一样。相信我，它不会倒闭的。是的，但这就是我开始的地方。我的博客——我当时根本不知道自己在做什么，我只是创建了这个博客，只是想把这些
knowledge out there like i said and it was it is technical content some of it was stuff based on agile and scrum that i was experiencing with the teams and i was really just blogging like i think about three times a week and that was all i really thought of it but then some weird stuff started to happen like i'd start to get a bunch of emails and all these opportunities started opening up i got invited to do courses for a online training company called Pluralsight when they were first starting out. That was a really good opportunity. I got phone calls from people wanting to hire me for jobs, not to interview me for jobs, but to hire me for jobs because they read my blog. I remember thinking, wow, this is just crazy.
知识分享出去。正如我所说，这其中包含一些技术内容，有些是基于我在团队中经历的敏捷和 Scrum 的内容。我当时真的只是每周写三次博客，这就是我当时所有的想法。但后来发生了一些奇怪的事情，我开始收到大量的电子邮件，各种机会也随之而来。我受邀为一家名为 Pluralsight 的在线培训公司制作课程，当时他们刚起步。那是一个非常好的机会。我接到了人们打来的电话，想雇我工作，不是为了面试，而是直接雇佣，因为他们读了我的博客。我记得当时想，哇，这简直太疯狂了。
I wasn't intentionally going out there trying to market myself, but I did. And I just ended up going. I remember the first podcast I did was Hansel Minutes way back then. It was like Scott Hanselman was this big star to me back then. And here I was on his podcast. And all my coworkers were like, man, I heard you on Hansel Minutes podcast. And I started to realize, man, I heard you on Hanselman. It's popular. That's awesome. And I started to realize, wow, this is interesting. So I started doing some talks on how to market yourself as a software developer because I accidentally did this.
我并不是刻意去推销自己，但我确实做到了。我记得我参加的第一个播客是 Hansel Minutes。那时候 Scott Hanselman 对我来说就是个大明星，而我竟然上了他的播客。我所有的同事都说：“嘿，我在 Hansel Minutes 的播客上听到你了。”我开始意识到，哇，这很有趣。所以我开始做一些关于如何作为软件开发人员推销自己的演讲，因为我无意中做到了这一点。
And then I started intentionally doing it. And it was, I mean, my career was taken off. I spent 14 years honing my technical skills and no one cared. But as soon as I figured out the soft skills, how to communicate and talk and do those things and market myself and build a brand, bam, everything started to take off. So I gave a couple of talks and people were just enthralled with that. I was talking to people after a conference in CodeCamp, it was like five, six hours, no one was doing this content. And so to fast forward to where things are now, what ended up happening was I started to realize that even though I had created a bunch of technical training content,
然后我开始有意识地去做。我的职业生涯开始腾飞。我花了 14 年时间磨练技术，没人关心。但一旦我掌握了软技能，学会了如何沟通、交谈、做这些事情，推销自己并建立个人品牌，砰，一切都开始起飞了。所以我做了几次演讲，人们对此非常着迷。我在 CodeCamp 会议后和人们交谈，聊了五六个小时，当时没人做这方面的内容。所以快进到今天，最终发生的事情是，我开始意识到，尽管我制作了大量技术培训内容，
I ended up doing that, I just ended up having all these great career opportunities. I started to realize that my heart was really for personal development and helping the developer and that no one was doing this. There was this big hole in what you could call life coaching or personal development for software developers and soft skills, all of that that's kind of rolled into their self-helpy type of things that people make fun of but are really beneficial in life. And it was super beneficial in my life right i went from an introverted shy kind of afraid to talk to girls guy that that was bold and out there and and and and stop being lazy and conquering my you know conquering things and
我最终获得了所有这些绝佳的职业机会。我开始意识到，我真正热爱的是个人发展，是帮助开发人员，而当时没人做这个。在所谓的“人生教练”或针对软件开发人员的个人发展以及软技能方面，存在一个巨大的空白。所有这些都被归入人们会嘲笑但实际上对生活非常有益的“自助”类事物中。这对我的人生非常有益。我从一个内向、害羞、不敢和女生说话的家伙，变成了一个大胆、外向、不再懒惰、能够征服困难的人，
and becoming an entrepreneur and i wanted to teach other people how to do that so really what simple programmer ended up becoming and what my mission is now, I actually sort of, I'd say retired like four years ago because I hit my passive income goal, but then I decided I'm going to pursue this full time. And so Simple Programmer has really become the place where developers can go to improve themselves, to reach their potential as human beings and to find fulfillment and happiness in their lives, not just from a technical perspective. A lot of it now, a lot of my content is out on YouTube and the podcast. I still have the blog that's still going.
并成为了一名企业家。我想教别人如何做到这一点。所以 Simple Programmer 最终变成了现在的样子，我的使命也发生了转变。我其实在四年前就“退休”了，因为我达到了被动收入目标，但我决定全职追求这个事业。因此，Simple Programmer 真正成为了开发人员提升自我、发挥人类潜能、在生活中寻找成就感和幸福感的地方，而不仅仅是从技术角度出发。现在，我的大部分内容都在 YouTube 和播客上。我依然保留着博客，它还在持续更新。
Yeah, that's basically it. It's grown to a company. We've got three full-time employees and a few part-time employees. So it's grown to this huge, massive thing. And it's all based on that whole idea now of personal development for software developers. Cool. That makes sense. I mean, one thing that kind of is amazing that a lot of people don't pick up on, you know, when I read, you know, let's say Business Insider or one of these kind of like,
是的，基本就是这样。它已经发展成了一家公司。我们有三名全职员工和几名兼职员工。所以它已经成长为一个庞大的事物。而这一切现在都基于“为软件开发人员提供个人发展”这一理念。酷。这很有道理。我的意思是，有一件事很神奇，很多人没有注意到，当我阅读《商业内幕》或这类主流新闻机构的文章时，
you know, news, you know, kind of mainstream news organizations, is this idea that if you look at what percent, you know, a company such as Intel or Google or Facebook or any of these Apple or any of these companies, the percent that they spend on their salary on compensation is at the level of the medical field. used to be just doctors, lawyers, and just a few other kind of niche areas. And in all the other places, the majority of the expense was in capital costs, maybe servers, or you're buying a power plant or something like that, right? But now with high tech, you have engineers who sort of are in that position where basically a company like Google sells, you know, what crackles of energy over the Internet. Right. And so their their their biggest expense are their people.
你会发现，像英特尔、谷歌、Facebook、苹果或任何这些公司，他们在薪酬上投入的比例已经达到了医疗行业的水平。过去这通常只是医生、律师和少数几个利基领域。在其他所有地方，大部分支出都在资本成本上，比如服务器，或者购买发电厂之类的，对吧？但现在在高科技领域，工程师们处于这样的位置：像谷歌这样的公司，通过互联网销售能量的火花。所以他们最大的支出是人力。
And also that's their biggest source of income. Like it's entirely driven by people. And so that's why, you know, there's there's a lot-hanging fruit that people can grab in their personal life as software engineers. Like just by sort of developing sort of this marketing, this negotiation, and sort of you can raise sort of your own value as an engineer, it's incredibly important. And it's something that, you know, hasn't been typically afforded to engineers. As I said, it was something that was really not part of this profession. So we have a lot of catching up to do. Oh, yeah, yeah, definitely. You're, you're, you're very right. Especially there's a huge amount of opportunity, especially, you know, I always talk about the
这也是他们最大的收入来源。它完全是由人驱动的。这就是为什么作为软件工程师，人们在个人生活中有很多唾手可得的果实。仅仅通过发展这种营销、谈判能力，你就可以提升自己作为工程师的价值，这极其重要。而且，这通常不是工程师所具备的。正如我所说，这在过去确实不是这个职业的一部分。所以我们有很多需要追赶的地方。哦，是的，绝对没错。你是对的。尤其是这里有巨大的机会，我总是谈论
commoditization of software development. And it's really coming. I mean, when I hire developers, I hire developers on Upwork to do work for me, and I can get, like, here's the thing, and this is what it is, is if I can be very specific in what I want, and I can describe it really well, which most managers and project managers cannot do, I can get programming labor done for extremely cheap, like ridiculously cheap. But so what I'm saying is that it's no longer good enough to just be a programmer, right? It's writing code and the technology part of it. Yes, there's still a premium on it, but that's fading away quickly with the globalization, right, with a world economy. But what won't fade away with the thing that's going to set you apart, that thing that's going to stop the commoditization
软件开发的商品化。它真的要来了。我的意思是，当我雇佣开发人员时，我会在 Upwork 上雇人帮我工作。事情是这样的：如果我能非常具体地说明我想要什么，并且能很好地描述它——大多数经理和项目经理做不到这一点——我就能以极低的价格获得编程劳动力，简直低得离谱。所以我想说的是，仅仅做一个程序员已经不够了，对吧？编写代码和技术部分，是的，它仍然有溢价，但随着全球化和世界经济的发展，这种溢价正在迅速消失。但不会消失的是那些能让你脱颖而出的东西，那些能阻止商品化
from taking your job as a software developer is going to be the communication. It's going to be the soft skills. It's going to be the, the person, the personality and being the person that understands the bigger thing that can, that can run with the project and communicate to other people on the team. That's the biggest thing that I think. So that's why I think there is still this, and software developers that are highly valuable are more like doctors and lawyers and so much spend is on salaries because they're not really paying, I think personally that tech that most companies
夺走你软件开发工作的东西，将是沟通能力。将是软技能。将是你的个性，以及成为那个能理解大局、能推进项目并与团队中其他人沟通的人。我认为这是最重要的事情。这就是为什么我认为仍然存在这种情况，那些高价值的软件开发人员更像医生和律师。大多数公司在薪水上投入巨大，因为我认为，大多数公司
aren't paying necessarily for the technical aptitude anymore because there's a lot of that all over the place but the and this also goes to speak to why so many developers tell me oh i get why does everyone say that developers are in such high demand but i can't get a job it is because no it's not just programming it's not just the technical skills it's not just developers that are in high demand it's highly functioning developers that not only possess technical skills but have the the soft skills and the people skills and those kind of skills that in conjunction with those technical skills those are the valuable ones that's what everybody wants and that's that's what's high in demand.
不再仅仅为技术能力买单，因为到处都是技术能力。这也解释了为什么这么多开发人员告诉我：“哦，我明白了，为什么每个人都说开发人员需求量很大，但我却找不到工作？”这是因为，不，不仅仅是编程，不仅仅是技术技能，不仅仅是开发人员需求量大，而是那些高功能的开发人员，他们不仅拥有技术技能，还拥有软技能和人际交往能力。这些技能与技术技能相结合，才是最有价值的，才是每个人都想要的，才是需求量大的。
Everything else will be commoditized. At least that's my prediction for the future. Yeah, and I think it's incredibly possible now to build a brand with no resources at all. I mean, people know this. We've mentioned it. We have, I mean, now thanks to Patreon and some of these things, we have some funds. We can actually spend a little bit on advertising. But we went years without doing any advertising at all, just 100%, just organic, just putting out shows that we would find entertaining,
其他一切都会被商品化。至少这是我对未来的预测。是的，而且我认为现在完全有可能在没有任何资源的情况下建立个人品牌。人们都知道这一点。我们提到过，现在多亏了 Patreon 和一些平台，我们有一些资金。我们可以花一点钱做广告。但我们多年来根本没有做任何广告，完全是 100% 有机增长，只是发布我们觉得有趣的内容，
really putting out shows for our children to be able to watch later if they're interested, listen to later. And it just kind of grew. The brand just kind of grew completely organically um and now more and more companies are looking at uh your github profile uh your your hacker news rank or whatever you know all of these all of these things that uh kind of can represent you that you can cultivate um you know without having you know a massive army of resources or without having been born into any kind of family or anything like that. As long as you have a computer, you can sort of build a brand.
真正为我们的孩子制作节目，以便他们以后感兴趣时可以观看或收听。它就这样成长起来了。品牌完全是自然增长的。现在越来越多的公司在查看你的 GitHub 个人资料、你的 Hacker News 排名，或者任何能代表你、你可以培养的东西，而无需拥有庞大的资源，也不需要出生在什么特殊的家庭。只要你有一台电脑，你就可以建立一个品牌。
And that's also something that's kind of unique to maybe this or the past generation, right? Oh, yeah. Yeah, definitely. I mean, I've got a similar you know with simple programmer i i mean we do maybe like you know around fifty thousand dollars a month in revenue and i have not my advertising budget is almost nothing right we don't spend any money advertising it's just all organic it all built up from me with a blog i mean like what's like seven or eight years ago and and just pumping out content. And that's, I mean, that's the thing.
这也是可能属于这一代或上一代所独有的东西，对吧？哦，是的。绝对是。我的意思是，我也有类似的经历。在 Simple Programmer，我们每月的收入大约是五万美元，而我的广告预算几乎为零。我们不花钱做广告，全是自然增长，都是我七八年前通过博客积累起来的，只是不断地输出内容。这就是关键。
Like, if you create value in the world, you've got an opportunity now, right? You know, I did, and I've done it on multiple platforms. You know, on YouTube, I put out two to three YouTube videos a day. And that, just by creating that much value, you're going to build a brand. If you're willing to do the work, I guess that's what I'm saying, is that you've got the opportunity like there has never been in the world before for someone to build a personal brand, to be an entrepreneur, but not necessarily even just to be an entrepreneur, just the programmer who builds their own personal brand, who builds a blog or creates some YouTube. I just interviewed a guy today who created a YouTube channel after doing some of my marketing courses, how to market yourself course.
如果你在世界上创造价值，你现在就有机会，对吧？我在多个平台上都做到了。在 YouTube 上，我每天发布两到三个视频。仅仅通过创造那么多的价值，你就能建立一个品牌。如果你愿意付出努力，我想说的是，你拥有前所未有的机会去建立个人品牌，去成为一名企业家。甚至不一定要成为企业家，仅仅是作为一个建立自己个人品牌的程序员，建立一个博客或创建一些 YouTube 频道。我今天刚采访了一个人，他在参加了我的营销课程（如何推销自己课程）后创建了一个 YouTube 频道。
In two years, he's built it up and he's been getting all kinds of job offers and contract jobs. He's able to freelance without having to go out there and pound the pavement. And so that opportunity is just amazing that we have today to be able to do that. And I think so many developers aren't taking advantage of it. That's the thing that I don't understand is it doesn't take a huge amount of effort to build yourself a personal brand and to build a blog and to do some of this stuff. And the payoff is so great when you do that. One thing I always compare it to is like, you know, if you've ever been to, if you've
在两年内，他建立了自己的频道，并获得了各种工作机会和合同工作。他能够自由职业，而不必到处奔波。我们今天拥有的这种机会真是太棒了。而且我认为很多开发人员并没有利用它。我不明白这一点，因为建立个人品牌、建立博客和做这些事情并不需要付出巨大的努力。当你这样做时，回报是非常巨大的。我总是把它比作，如果你曾经去过，如果你
ever heard like a cover band play, right? And they play some song that is by some famous band, right? Right. And sometimes I go and I listen to a cover band and I'm like, they're better than the original. Yeah. And sometimes I go and I listen to a cover band and I'm like, they're better than the original. One time I went to a karaoke bar and there was a lady who sang songs better than the original. It was amazing.
听过翻唱乐队演奏，对吧？他们演奏一些著名乐队的歌曲，对吧？没错。有时我去听翻唱乐队，我觉得他们比原唱还好。是的。有时我去听翻唱乐队，我觉得他们比原唱还好。有一次我去卡拉 OK 酒吧，有一位女士唱的歌比原唱还好。太神奇了。
Yeah. And so I did this enough times. And same thing with celebrity chefs. And you can find this in a lot of places. And it's not like you don't, like I'm saying that you can get away with no talent but what i'm saying is that the thing that differentiates the cover band from metallica or you know whatever band is not the skill it's not the skill it's the same thing in programming it's the marketing it's it's the style it's it's that piece of it and so i mean you can't you can't fake it you can't not have the technical skills.
是的。我经历过很多次这种情况。名厨也是一样。你可以在很多地方发现这一点。并不是说你不需要天赋，但我说的是，区分翻唱乐队和 Metallica 或其他乐队的不是技能，不是技能，编程也是一样。是营销，是风格，是那一部分。所以，我的意思是，你不能伪造它，你不能没有技术技能。
But for so many developers, the greater amount of effort, if they spent more effort right now with the technical skills they have in developing a personal brand and learning how to market themselves, they would have a much greater lever than they would have by increasing their technical skills further. It's just like the cover band. It's the same phenomenon. And I saw it in my career, and I've seen it in so many developers' careers. That makes sense. I mean, I have a friend who, he's actually pretty successful. He's in finance, but he had some trouble in his past. So he had some trouble with alcohol and he got convicted.
但对于许多开发人员来说，如果他们现在投入更多的精力在利用现有技术技能来发展个人品牌和学习如何推销自己上，他们将比进一步提高技术技能获得更大的杠杆作用。这就像翻唱乐队一样。这是同样的现象。我在我的职业生涯中看到了这一点，我也在许多开发人员的职业生涯中看到了这一点。这很有道理。我的意思是，我有一个朋友，他其实挺成功的。他在金融行业，但过去遇到过一些麻烦。他有酗酒问题，并被定罪了。
I think it's like a DUI. I believe it's like a felony. I don't know the details. But basically, if you Googled him, you got mugshots.com as the first link. And he's saying, you know, look, I paid some people that were supposed to take this off and it did go off, but then Google found it again. And, and he's trying to sort of get these links off. And I said, instead of trying to remove, cause you know, it's Google, they're going to find this somehow. Right. So instead of trying to remove, you know, this, why don't you build, you know, uh, just some, I mean, I didn't call it a brand at
我想是酒驾之类的。我相信是重罪。我不知道细节。但基本上，如果你在谷歌上搜索他，第一个链接就是 mugshots.com。他说：“看，我付钱给一些人，让他们把这个删掉，确实删掉了，但后来谷歌又找到了。”他试图把这些链接删掉。我说，与其试图删除——因为你知道，那是谷歌，他们总会找到的，对吧？所以与其试图删除这个，为什么你不建立，你知道，我当时没称之为品牌，
the time, but I said, why don't you just build a persona online and just cultivate that and post pictures and talk about finance and build something that where people will know the modern you and where that will be the people's first impression. I mean, at the end of the day, if you're looking for a job and you've had these issues, it's going to come up like there's going to be a background check and so on and so forth. The best thing you can do is build a brand, like project the version of you that you want. And that's kind of an extreme case where this person has this problem. But I think it could be advice given to everybody is there's effectively some type of noise about you right now there is a brand it's like effectively let's say random whether it's good or bad um but you can
但我说，为什么你不直接在网上建立一个人设，培养它，发布照片，谈论金融，建立一些东西，让人们了解现代的你，并成为人们的第一印象。我的意思是，归根结底，如果你在找工作，而你有这些问题，它总会出现，会有背景调查等等。你能做的最好的事情就是建立一个品牌，投射出你想要的那个版本的自己。这是一种极端情况，这个人有这个问题。但我认为这可以作为给所有人的建议：现在关于你确实存在某种噪音，有一个品牌，它基本上是随机的，无论好坏。但你可以
take control of that um by by sort of building a persona for yourself online and and and turn it into something that you're really proud of. Oh, definitely. Oh, good. Yeah, so I was going to say, I think the only thing with all this to caution people is that you got to use time. It's like the same thing as like investing. People invest money and think like, how do I double my money in the next year? It's like, you don't.
通过在网上为自己建立一个人设来掌控它，并把它变成你真正引以为傲的东西。哦，绝对。哦，好。是的，我想说的是，我认为所有这些事情唯一需要提醒人们的是，你必须利用时间。这就像投资一样。人们投资金钱，心想：“我怎么能在明年让钱翻倍？”答案是：你做不到。
Oh, yeah, that's true. Or you gamble it and it goes away. So I think people look for this, like I'm going to start a blog. I posted twice to it and then I didn't get a million followers and a big exit. And it's like, well, no, of course not. You do it over years.
哦，是的，那是真的。或者你赌博，然后钱就没了。所以我认为人们在寻找这种东西，比如“我要开个博客”。我发了两篇，然后我没有获得一百万粉丝，也没有大获成功。这就像，好吧，当然不会。你要花几年时间去做。
Like you post blog every day or once a week. You pick a schedule, but then you stick to it. And it's over a long period of time you sort of get that compounding interest effect. I mean, I guess we'd have to think about it economically and puzzle it out if it truly is a sort of exponential thing. But, you know, in my head, it sort of maps that way, which is like you do these things over the course of a career and you build a brand. You know, it isn't that you can't buy the marketing, you can't buy the spot in Google, but posting enough things over the course of, you know, a year, two years, that's very
比如你每天或每周发一篇博客。你选定一个时间表，然后坚持下去。经过很长一段时间，你就会获得那种复利效应。我的意思是，我想我们必须从经济学角度思考并推敲一下它是否真的是一种指数级增长。但是，在我的脑海里，它就是这样映射的，就像你在职业生涯中做这些事情，然后建立一个品牌。你知道，你不能买营销，你不能买谷歌上的位置，但通过在一年、两年内发布足够多的内容，那是非常
beneficial. And it shows, you know, employers consistency, right? Like, if I go to your website, and it looks like you threw it together last night, or your GitHub has one, you know, project on it that you committed to once, that's not actually that interesting. But if you sort of are doing little bits of effort over the course of a very long period of time, then it's like, wow, I see much more of a better picture of this person. Yeah, that's actually a really good point. I think a lot of people have goals.
有益的。而且它向雇主展示了你的持续性，对吧？如果我访问你的网站，看起来像是你昨晚随便拼凑的，或者你的 GitHub 上只有一个你提交过一次的项目，那其实并不吸引人。但如果你在很长一段时间内一点一点地努力，那么就会像：“哇，我对这个人有了更全面的了解。”是的，这确实是一个很好的观点。我认为很多人都有目标。
And I actually, I mean, you know, goal is just a word. I don't want to say I'm against goals. It's kind of like being against Christmas or something, right? But I feel like it's better to have a system than a goal. Like, for example, this year I really wanted to remove, like, declutter my life, right? And so I could say I want a goal to declutter, but it's kind of, it's really hard to. The other thing about goals is they're kind of designed for you not to reach them. Like, have you ever seen one of these charity goals where they just meet it and they say, we're done?
而且我其实，你知道，目标只是一个词。我不想说我反对目标。这就像反对圣诞节之类的，对吧？但我感觉拥有一个系统比拥有一个目标更好。例如，今年我真的想清除生活中的杂乱，对吧？所以我可以说我有一个清除杂乱的目标，但这很难。关于目标的另一件事是，它们的设计初衷往往让你无法达到。你见过那种慈善目标吗？他们一旦达到就说：“我们完成了。”
No, right? They always set the goal to something they know they're not going to reach, right? So instead, I said, look, every day I'm going to go through my email and I'm going to unsubscribe. If there's something that I can unsubscribe from, I'm going to do it, you know, if I'm not interested. And so I created this sort of system and it became kind of a metaphor for kind of unsubscribing myself to things at work that I'm not using anymore, you know, things. But that became kind of like that system became an anchor for other things. And the podcast is kind of the same way.
不，对吧？他们总是把目标定在他们知道自己无法达到的高度，对吧？所以相反，我说：“看，每天我都要检查我的电子邮件，然后取消订阅。如果有什么我可以取消订阅的，我就去做，如果我不感兴趣的话。”所以我创建了这个系统，它成为了一种隐喻，用来取消订阅我在工作中不再使用的东西。但那个系统成为了其他事情的锚点。播客也是一样。
We really wanted to educate. And for the first maybe two years, it was just, you know, our moms listening. And I was fine. Oh, my mom stopped listening. That's true. And it was fine because we had this sort of system and we were we were building stuff that we were kind of proud of. And then eventually, you know, we had this sort of geometric increase in the number of people. But, yeah, it's as Patrick said, it's really important just kind of you could obviously have a vision for what you want your future to look like.
我们真的很想教育他人。前两年可能只有我们的妈妈在听。我没关系。哦，我妈妈不听了。那是真的。没关系，因为我们有这个系统，我们在制作我们引以为傲的东西。然后最终，你知道，我们的人数有了几何级的增长。但是，是的，正如 Patrick 所说，这非常重要，你显然可以对你想要的未来有一个愿景。
Like in case of my friend, he obviously wants to have a future. We can go on Google, type his name and get really nice things. It's fine to have that projection, but yeah, it's really important to build sort of the system that's going to ramp you up and take you there. Oh yeah. There's a book, if you haven't read it already,
就像我朋友的情况，他显然想要一个未来。我们可以去谷歌，输入他的名字，得到非常好的结果。有这种投射是可以的，但是的，建立一个能让你不断进步并带你到达那里的系统非常重要。哦，是的。有一本书，如果你还没读过，
I'm sure you would love it. It's by Scott Adams. It's called How to L scott adams it's called how to win how to lose that everything and still win big and in that book he's he's basically and it's the same mindset that i have which you just described which is he he says don't use goals create systems instead and that's i mean that has been the secret to my success by far is is creating systems and And again, to what you guys talked about, it takes time. I always say consistency, commitment, persistence. That's the formula for success because you have to be consistent.
我相信你会喜欢的。是 Scott Adams 写的。书名叫《如何失败并依然大获全胜》（How to Fail at Almost Everything and Still Win Big）。在那本书里，他基本上——这和我刚才描述的思维方式一样——他说：“不要设定目标，要创建系统。”这就是我成功的秘诀，远超其他。创建系统。再次回到你们刚才谈到的，这需要时间。我总是说：持续性、承诺、坚持。这就是成功的公式，因为你必须持续。
You can't just release random podcast episodes or YouTube videos or blog posts. And you have to be committed. You have to do it rain or shine, whether you've got good content or not. I mean, sometimes I make YouTube videos and it's like, if I'm doing two to three YouTube videos a day, I'm not always in the best of spirits. Sometimes I don't have any wisdom to share and I'm like, wow, this is going to suck, but I'm going to release it anyway because I'm going to suck in public, right? I think our podcasts are always awesome yeah right i think it's important yet to be authentic too i think some of the times where you know we've recorded sometimes where one of us was sick or down or
你不能只是随机发布播客剧集、YouTube 视频或博客文章。你必须做出承诺。你必须风雨无阻地去做，无论你是否有好的内容。我的意思是，有时我制作 YouTube 视频，如果我每天做两到三个视频，我并不总是处于最佳状态。有时我没有任何智慧可以分享，我想：“哇，这太烂了。”但我还是会发布它，因为我要在公众面前表现得很烂，对吧？我认为我们的播客总是很棒。是的，对吧？我认为保持真实也很重要。我觉得有时我们录制的时候，我们其中一个人病了或情绪低落，
something like that and of course sometimes it comes through but i think actually the time where you sort of struggle people kind of pick up on that. And they say and I feel like sometimes that actually builds a way stronger relationship than the ninety nine other shows where everyone was was healthy and fit. Oh, definitely. Yeah. One hundred percent agree with you. One thing that that has really helped me, especially with the YouTube, is just focusing on, you know, I've got to post on my board to be genuine, always genuine, you know, and that's, it's so important. You have to show some of your vulnerability, right? And vulnerability and weakness are two different things. When you show vulnerability, it actually shows strength because if I did this video
或者类似的情况，当然有时会表现出来。但我认为实际上你挣扎的时候，人们反而能感受到。我觉得有时这比其他 99 期每个人都健康、状态良好的节目建立了更牢固的关系。哦，绝对。是的，百分之百同意你。有一件事对我帮助很大，特别是在 YouTube 上，就是专注于——我在我的板子上写了要保持真实，永远真实，你知道，这太重要了。你必须展示你的一些脆弱性，对吧？脆弱和软弱是两回事。当你展示脆弱时，它实际上展示了力量。因为如果我做这个视频，
and I was talking about like, you know, in Braveheart, you know, where they turn around and they lift up their kilts, right? Showing their butt. So they're making themselves vulnerable to their opponent there, right? So you don't like reveal your butt to your opponent where they could hack at it unless you're feeling pretty strong. When you show the vulnerability, it actually shows a lot of strength, but that connection, it also shows that you're human. That's the key thing. People know that you make mistakes.
谈论像《勇敢的心》里那样，他们转身掀起苏格兰短裙，露出屁股。所以他们向对手展示了脆弱，对吧？所以你不会向对手露出屁股，除非你感觉自己足够强大。当你展示脆弱时，它实际上展示了很大的力量，但那种联系也表明你是人类。这是关键。人们知道你会犯错。
You want people, especially if you want to inspire people. One thing I've learned in this self-development is that I can't just be like, look how awesome I am. I have to be like, look at, I'm just like you. I'm just like you, right? I screw up just like you. I still screw up just like you. But there's a difference and I'm getting to where I want to get in life and I can show you how to do it too. Here's my hand.
你希望人们，特别是如果你想激励人们的话。我在个人发展中学到的一件事是，我不能只是表现得“看我多棒”。我必须表现得“看，我和你一样。我和你一样，对吧？我和你一样会搞砸。我依然像你一样会搞砸。”但有区别，我正在实现我的人生目标，我也可以教你怎么做。这是我的手。
Let's go together as opposed to, oh, yeah, yeah, you know, you guys suck and you're doing it wrong. And I never do anything wrong. That's not a way to teach. It doesn't work in any kind of field. But to show that, to be genuine, to show that vulnerability, to say, look, hey, this is me. It's cool. I screw up all the time, too, in school. But, you know, we'll get there together.
让我们一起走，而不是“哦，你们太烂了，你们做错了。我从不犯错。”那不是教学方式。它在任何领域都不起作用。但要展示出来，要真实，要展示那种脆弱，要说：“看，嘿，这就是我。没关系。我在学校里也总是搞砸。但是，我们会一起到达那里。”
To me, that's always been the – even teaching technical content. I screw up all the time too in school, but we'll get there together. To me, that's always been the – even teaching technical content, I found – I did a bunch of courses for Pluralsight, and I found that that was the thing that helped set my courses apart was the fact that I'm willing to make some mistakes and own up to them and just, hey, I'm your buddy here. Let's figure this stuff out together. Yeah, so one thing that's always kind of a tricky thing, but I'd love to hear your insight is, you know, if you're, for example, I'm trying to get back into running. And so I have, I bought one of these watches that measures your heart rate. And so I'm getting kind of better every week and I can measure it, right? Or if you write code, you can kind of feel yourself getting better.
对我来说，这一直是——即使是教授技术内容。我在学校里也总是搞砸，但我们会一起到达那里。对我来说，这一直是——即使是教授技术内容，我发现——我为 Pluralsight 做了很多课程，我发现这正是让我的课程脱颖而出的原因：我愿意犯一些错误并承认它们，嘿，我是你的伙伴。让我们一起弄清楚这些东西。是的，有一件事总是很棘手，但我很想听听你的见解。比如，如果你正在——我正在尝试重新开始跑步。所以我买了一块测量心率的手表。所以我每周都在变好，我可以测量它，对吧？或者如果你写代码，你可以感觉到自己在进步。
You can measure it, lines of code or more ambitious projects. These things are generally kind of pretty easy to measure. Your wealth is everyone measures that every time they go to pay a bill or something. But some soft skills like negotiation or maybe the ability to strike up a conversation with a stranger. Some of these things are kind of hard to measure, your nonverbal communication. So how do you go about, you know, how do people know that they've taken your advice, applied it? How do they know they've actually improved? That's a good question.
你可以测量它，代码行数或更雄心勃勃的项目。这些事情通常很容易测量。你的财富，每个人在付账单时都会测量。但一些软技能，比如谈判，或者与陌生人交谈的能力。其中一些事情很难测量，比如你的非语言沟通。那么你是怎么做的？人们怎么知道他们采纳了你的建议并应用了它？他们怎么知道自己真的进步了？这是一个好问题。
I mean, that's, it depends. I would go kind of back to the goals, honestly, again, here in saying that, you know, to go to zoom out a little bit on this picture of what do you, what are you aiming for? Right. You know, sometimes I think that we, we aim for, it's not the goal, right? So like, I mean, I've, I've achieved goals. Like I had financial goals. I hit those fitness goal. You know, I've achieved a lot of the goals goals. I hit those, fitness goals. I've achieved a lot of the goals I set out in life, and I have found that on the other side of a goal is usually disappointment. And sometimes, honestly, you can go into depression because you made your life about this thing. You got there, and now what?
我的意思是，这取决于情况。老实说，我会回到目标的问题上，说你瞄准的是什么？对吧？你知道，有时我认为我们瞄准的是——这不是目标，对吧？所以，我的意思是，我已经实现了目标。我有财务目标。我达到了那些目标。健身目标。我已经实现了人生中设定的许多目标，我发现目标的另一面通常是失望。有时，老实说，你可能会陷入抑郁，因为你把生活建立在这件事上。你达到了，然后呢？
And I've learned a lesson, you know, from doing that. And what I've sort of realized is that it's never about what like for me, all the things I'm aspiring to do now are all about the kind of person that I become in the process of achieving that goal or going down that path. The goal that I never really achieve. Right. It's about. And so what I would say is that, you know, a long way to answer this question, but where I'm getting at with this is that for these kind of skills, for these kind of soft skills, I mean, so if I could give you a badge and say you're a level 10 negotiator, ding, what if that really gets you, right? It's like, okay, so, you know, it's more of a, I look at it in terms of I want to maximize my potential and I want to show you how to maximize your potential. And to be honest, like I was doing this video just the other day because I went and I got my body fat measured at the gym. Wait, hang on.
我从中学到了教训。我意识到，这从来不是关于——对我来说，我现在渴望做的所有事情，都是关于我在实现目标或走上那条道路的过程中成为了什么样的人。那个我从未真正实现的目标。对吧？它是关于。所以我想说的是，这是一个漫长的回答，但我想表达的是，对于这些技能，对于这些软技能，如果我能给你一个徽章说你是 10 级谈判者，叮，那真的能给你带来什么吗？所以，你知道，我更多地是从我想最大化我的潜能，我想向你展示如何最大化你的潜能的角度来看待它。老实说，我前几天做这个视频是因为我去健身房测量了体脂。等等，等等。
How do you do that? What does that mean? Oh, like where they check your body fat level? Is that – oh, is that like the – because I know there's BMI, right? Where they weigh you and they get your height and they do some math. But is this, this sounds like something like more sophisticated. There's a lot of ways to do it. The way that they had to do it at the gym was using calipers.
你是怎么做的？那是什么意思？哦，就像他们检查你的体脂水平？那是——哦，那是——因为我知道有 BMI，对吧？他们称你的体重，测量你的身高，然后做一些数学计算。但这听起来更复杂。有很多方法可以做到。他们在健身房使用的方法是使用卡尺。
Like, so it's a skin fold caliper that checks the thickness of your skin at different points. Got it. skinfold caliper that checks the thickness of your skin at different points got it and and of course i've got you know i've done a dexa scan which is like a radio act or a dual radio image rescan they use it for like bone density i'm actually doing one on saturday but but when i went there i mean most most people like i i'm a i'm a youtube channel guest that i'm probably like you know seven and a half eight percent body fat or so and and that's where I kind of pegged myself and the guy measured at 11%. And I was talking about how like, man, I, like I, I could be pissed, right? I could be like, oh, that's not right. This you like measured again, right?
就像，这是一种皮褶卡尺，可以检查你不同部位的皮肤厚度。明白了。皮褶卡尺，可以检查你不同部位的皮肤厚度。明白了。当然，我做过 DEXA 扫描，这是一种双能 X 射线吸收扫描，他们用它来测量骨密度。我周六还要做一个。但当我去那里时，大多数人——我是 YouTube 频道的嘉宾，我可能大约是 7.5% 到 8% 的体脂，我把自己定在这个水平，而那个人测量出是 11%。我当时在谈论，天哪，我可能会很生气，对吧？我可能会说：“哦，那不对。你再测一次，对吧？”
Or I could be, or I could be excited about that and, and be happy that man, I, if I want to get down, like I've got more room to go. There's more low-hanging fruit than I thought, right? I feel like I look great now. I could look better, right? So my point of it was I talked about this idea of like when you measure something, like when you measure a foot, use a 13-inch ruler instead of an 11-inch, right? Although we want to go through life and we want to use these 11 inch rulers to measure a foot. Like we want to stretch it and say, oh yeah,
或者我可以换个角度，或者我可以为此感到兴奋，并为自己感到高兴，伙计，如果我想进步，我还有很大的空间。还有比我预想中更容易实现的目标，对吧？我觉得我现在看起来很棒。但我还可以看起来更好，对吧？所以我的观点是，我谈到了这样一个概念：当你衡量某样东西时，比如当你测量一英尺时，用一把13英寸的尺子而不是11英寸的，对吧？尽管我们想在生活中用这些11英寸的尺子去衡量一英尺。就像我们想把它拉长，然后说，哦，是的，
I got it. I hit the goal. Look, my net worth is a million dollars or whatever. You know what I mean? Like whatever it is, but use the 13 inch ruler. So then you know you got it. And that's how I feel about some of these things that are hard to measure. It's like, okay, have I, have I over, you know, I do a lot of coaching for guys, like dating coaching and, and teach them how to go. And I, I, I'll just put it plainly and say, pick up chicks, but that, you know, to, to go in and overcome their social anxiety, right. To be able to go in and talk to, to women, it is difficult for guys to do a lot of guys in our field. Right. And, and the thing is like, you know, whether you got it or not, you know, whether you're afraid or not, you know, right. Deep down for a lot of things, we could use an objective.
我做到了。我达到了目标。你看，我的净资产是一百万美元之类的。你知道我的意思吗？不管是什么，但要用那把13英寸的尺子。这样你就知道你真的做到了。这就是我对一些难以衡量的事情的看法。就像，好吧，我是不是，我是不是过度了，你知道，我为很多小伙子做辅导，比如约会辅导，教他们怎么做。我，我，我会直截了当地说，去搭讪女孩，但那，你知道，去克服他们的社交焦虑，对吧。能够去和女性交谈，这对很多小伙子来说很难，在我们这个领域有很多小伙子。对吧。关键是，你知道，无论你是否做到了，你知道，无论你是否害怕，你知道，对吧。在内心深处，对于很多事情，我们可以使用一个客观的。
We could use a measure and say, Oh, you know, like I said, you know, measuring with the ruler and we could say, Oh yeah, yeah, I'm, I'm, I'm really, I'm here, but it doesn't matter because that's, again, that's that goal thinking as if having some number, as if my body fat were 8%, if that would now magically make me. What I'm ultimately trying to do is look good when I look in the mirror. That's the ultimate perspective, right? That's the ultimate thing. And so the same thing, it's like an integrity issue. It's not something that you can necessarily measure from an external viewpoint, but you know it.
我们可以使用一个衡量标准，说，哦，你知道，就像我说的，用尺子测量，我们可以说，哦，是的，是的，我，我，我真的，我到了这里，但这并不重要，因为那又是那种目标思维，好像有了某个数字，好像我的体脂率是8%，如果那现在能神奇地让我变得怎样。我最终想要做的是在照镜子时看起来不错。那是最终的视角，对吧？那是最终的目标。所以同样的事情，这就像一个诚信问题。它不一定能从外部视角来衡量，但你自己心里清楚。
You know where you're at, and you know if you're improving, it you know where you're at and you know if you're improving and you know if you're faking it and you're like you could lie to the world and and you could appear to be super successful and you could appear to be progressing in all these areas but if deep down you know that you're not where you want to be or where you should be that's that that's your integrity that's that's the thing that that counts and matters in the end yeah that makes sense. And that's not the goal. I think it's super important to be honest with yourself.
你知道你处于什么位置，你知道你是否在进步，你知道你是否在伪装，你可以对世界撒谎，你可以看起来非常成功，你可以看起来在所有这些领域都在进步，但如果内心深处你知道你没有达到你想要或应该达到的位置，那就是你的诚信，那是最终算数和重要的事情，是的，这很有道理。而且那不是目标。我认为对自己诚实是非常重要的。
That's one thing that, you know, that's kind of like a slippery slope. It's kind of hard to come back from. But it's really important to kind of stay there. Yeah, and personally, I use a lot of sort of these proxy systems. Like, for example, I mean, to give another example, there was one time where I decided I really wanted to look people in the eye when I was talking to them. And I could just kind of say that, but it's hard, especially when you work, you're super busy. It's hard to really make that a priority or keep it in your mind. So I said, I'm going to, when I'm at say the
这是一件，你知道，有点像滑坡效应的事情。很难回头。但保持这种状态真的很重要。是的，就我个人而言，我使用很多这种代理系统。例如，我的意思是，再举一个例子，有一次我决定在和别人交谈时真的要看着他们的眼睛。我可以随口说说，但这很难，尤其是当你工作时，你超级忙。很难真正把这当作优先事项或记在心里。所以我说，我要，当我在，比如说
grocery store or the bank, or I'm at one of these situations where I'm paying for something or I'm, you know, someone's providing me a service. When I signed the check or when I saw my name on the bill or whatever it is, I'm going to look the person in the eye at that point. I'm going to make that kind of a conscious part and i know that you know my i could have my head in the game at that point on you know focusing on that one thing and and then again like make that if i can do that consistently then that will sort of spread to you know because a lot of what we do is unconscious right i mean you talk about exactly non-verbal communication you talk about even you know maybe the way you say things, the way you dress, the way you conduct yourself.
杂货店或银行，或者我在支付某样东西或，你知道，有人为我提供服务的情况时。当我签支票或看到账单上的名字或任何东西时，我会在那一刻看着那个人的眼睛。我要把这变成一种有意识的行为，我知道，你知道，我的，我可以在那一刻全神贯注于那件事，然后，再次，如果我能持续做到这一点，那么它就会传播开来，你知道，因为我们所做的很多事情都是无意识的，对吧？我的意思是，你谈论的是非语言交流，你甚至谈论，你知道，也许你说话的方式，你的穿着方式，你的行为举止。
Life is just, there's so much going on in life and you can't really be conscious of all of it. So the vast majority of it is just your brain is just unconsciously doing things. Everything from walking, breathing, and then even higher level things. It's like someone throws a baseball at you what you do you just reach up and you catch it you instinctively or you block your face or something right and so you need to sort of develop those same unconscious instincts so when someone's you know asking you a super tough question in an interview that your sort of unconscious memory will kick in and you can maintain the eye contact, be friendly, be positive, even though
生活就是，生活中发生的事情太多了，你不可能真正意识到所有这些。所以绝大多数事情只是你的大脑在无意识地做。从走路、呼吸，甚至更高级的事情。就像有人向你扔棒球，你做什么，你只是伸手去接，你本能地或者你挡住脸之类的，对吧？所以你需要培养那些同样的无意识本能，这样当有人在面试中问你一个超级棘手的问题时，你的无意识记忆就会启动，你可以保持眼神交流，保持友好，保持积极，即使
you're flipping out because you have no idea what like my SQL is or something, right? So that's where I think, yeah, setting these sort of proxy goals, especially in situations where you have a lot of control, such as in the case where, you know, if I'm signing my name and handing it to somebody, I mean, I don't have to think about a lot of other things. I can sort of control where my eyes are. Then that can sort of give you the unconscious ability. It's kind of like if you ever take – I used to teach taekwondo. And a lot of taekwondo and self-defense and these things are to give you that unconscious ability. So when somebody kind of grabs you you you just your brain your unconscious
你快疯了，因为你根本不知道什么是MySQL之类的，对吧？所以我认为，是的，设定这些代理目标，特别是在你有很大控制权的情况下，比如，你知道，如果我在签名并把它交给某人时，我的意思是，我不必考虑很多其他事情。我可以控制我的眼睛在哪里。那么这可以给你那种无意识的能力。这有点像如果你曾经参加——我以前教跆拳道。很多跆拳道和自卫以及这些事情都是为了给你那种无意识的能力。所以当有人抓住你时，你的大脑，你的无意识
brain kind of just takes over you react you immediately do the thing you need to do and then you can consciously do the more important thing which is run away or something like that oh yeah yeah i totally agree it's funny that you say that with that about the eye contact too because i had this i had this exercise again for overcoming social anxiety and i had different levels of it and one of them was you know i did this video and i was talking about how like and i did this myself i i would go and i'd go for a run and i would make eye contact with with people and i would i would not be the person to break it and i would and the other rule was that you couldn't smile or nod your head because
大脑就会接管，你做出反应，你立即做你需要做的事情，然后你可以有意识地做更重要的事情，那就是逃跑之类的，哦，是的，是的，我完全同意，你说到眼神交流也很有趣，因为我也有这个练习，为了克服社交焦虑，我有不同的级别，其中之一是，你知道，我拍了这个视频，我谈到了如何，我自己也做了这个，我会去跑步，我会和人们进行眼神交流，我不会是那个先移开视线的人，另一个规则是你不能微笑或点头，因为
those were both signs of kind of weakness of like of deference right and so you just had to like not not like angrily staring people down but you just had to realize that there's no reason why you should break eye contact first you can control the frame if you choose and you have the power to do it and this is uncomfortable but and i strongly believe that the only way to grow everything that makes you grow in life is something that's uncomfortable and so i did that exercise myself it made me feel real uncomfortable at first and and a lot of a lot of people that subscribe to my channel did it and what what we found from this was that now it just became now we mastered that and we had it in that specific context like you said and now we just we just have the power to do it like you
这两者都是软弱或顺从的迹象，对吧？所以你只需要，不是像愤怒地盯着别人看，而是你只需要意识到没有理由先移开视线，如果你选择，你可以控制框架，你有能力做到这一点，这很不舒服，但我坚信，生活中让你成长的唯一途径就是做一些不舒服的事情，所以我自己做了那个练习，起初让我感到非常不舒服，很多订阅我频道的人也做了，我们发现的是，现在这已经成为了，现在我们掌握了它，我们在那个特定的情境中拥有了它，就像你说的，现在我们只是有能力做到这一点，就像你
don't even think about it it doesn't it's not even a thing because you've done it in such a difficult situation and i took it to some different levels of some other things but it's it makes a lot of sense i mean that's one of those things like you practice it over and over and then it becomes again same thing even i'd say like when i i just shot some videos today and i'm walking down the beach you know with my my phone and you know there's tons of people around i'm just walking talking to my phone but i've done it so many times now that i i'm not saying that i'm not self-aware at all but i it was uncomfortable at first but then it became a thing that became normal and now I can do it. But you got to step out of that comfort zone if you
甚至不用去想它，它甚至不是个事儿，因为你在如此困难的情况下做到了，我把它提升到了其他一些层面，但这很有道理，我的意思是，这是那种你一遍又一遍地练习，然后它就变成了，同样的事情，甚至我会说，就像我今天拍了一些视频，我走在海滩上，你知道，拿着我的手机，你知道周围有很多人，我只是边走边对着手机说话，但我已经做过很多次了，现在我不是说我一点也不在意别人的眼光，但起初这很不舒服，但后来它变成了一件正常的事情，现在我可以做到了。但你必须走出那个舒适区，如果你
want to be able to expand your ability in any of those areas. Yeah, that makes sense. So what do you think if you had to pick just one thing, maybe from your entire website, just one lesson that you wanted people to follow, you know, the most important, the most underdeveloped soft skill for software engineers. What do you think that would be? This is a tough one because it's going to change from day to day for me, like just from my perspective, right? I like to talk about looking at things from a different perspective. But the one that I fall back on a lot, even though it's not super exciting, like I want to say something more exciting. But honestly, I think this is the most valuable skill in life, period, is the ability to teach yourself, is learning how to learn. If you develop that skill, and it is a soft skill because there's not a technical way to do it.
想在任何这些领域扩展你的能力。是的，这很有道理。那么如果你必须只选一件事，也许从你的整个网站中，只选一个你希望人们遵循的课程，你知道，对软件工程师来说最重要、最不发达的软技能是什么？你认为那会是什么？这是一个难题，因为对我来说，它会每天都在变化，就像从我的角度来看，对吧？我喜欢谈论从不同的角度看问题。但我经常回归的那一个，尽管它不是特别令人兴奋，就像我想说一些更令人兴奋的事情。但老实说，我认为这是生活中最有价值的技能，句号，就是自学的能力，就是学会如何学习。如果你培养了那种技能，而且它是一种软技能，因为没有一种技术性的方法来做到这一点。
It's not learning one thing. It's the ability to acquire knowledge, the ability to self-educate, to teach yourself. This is one of those things that it's so – like if you can do this, and a lot of people think they can, but they can't. What they can do is they can go find teachers that tell them what to do. And that's not the same thing as teaching yourself. But if you can honestly figure out how to teach yourself and how to learn, how to learn, then the doors of the world open up to you. Like there's nothing that you can't do. You can, you want to become an entrepreneur. You want to build a business. You want to, you know, get this job. You want to learn this, you know, so many people, the people that, you know, you could go to the whole mindset, the fixed versus, what's it, elastic mindset viewpoint on this.
这不是学习一件事。这是获取知识的能力，自我教育的能力，自学的能力。这是那种非常——就像如果你能做到这一点，很多人认为他们可以，但他们不能。他们能做的是找到老师告诉他们该怎么做。那和自学是不一样的。但如果你能真正弄清楚如何自学以及如何学习，如何学习，那么世界的大门就会为你敞开。就像没有什么你做不到的。你可以，你想成为一名企业家。你想建立一家企业。你想，你知道，得到这份工作。你想学习这个，你知道，这么多人，那些，你知道，你可以去整个思维模式，固定与，是什么，弹性思维视角来看待这个问题。
But essentially, the people that I know, and, you know, I've had this experience a lot from YouTube just because of the kind of people that are on YouTube sometimes watching my videos and commenting on them are not the kind of people I would normally associate in daily life. And, and some of those people, their problem is very, very clear. They have a very fixed mindset. They don't know how to teach themselves. They don't believe it's possible. So, so, so much of life is shut to them. They, they, they have no ability to, to change a lot of their situation in life because they can't see it because they don't have that skill. If they, if they had that one skill, if they could just teach themselves, if they figured out that they could do that, everything would open to them. And the people that I see that are most successful in life are people that, that you basically would say, or the kind of people that would say, well, you know what, if I needed to become a lawyer,
但本质上，我认识的人，而且，你知道，我从YouTube上有很多这样的经验，仅仅是因为有时在YouTube上看我视频并评论的人，不是我日常生活中通常会交往的那种人。而且，其中一些人，他们的问题非常非常清楚。他们有非常固定的思维模式。他们不知道如何自学。他们不相信这是可能的。所以，生活中太多的东西对他们关闭了。他们，他们，他们没有能力改变他们生活中的很多状况，因为他们看不到，因为他们没有那种技能。如果他们，如果他们有那一种技能，如果他们能自学，如果他们发现他们能做到这一点，一切都会向他们敞开。而我看到的在生活中最成功的人，基本上你会说，或者那种会说，好吧，你知道吗，如果我需要成为一名律师，
I could become a lawyer. I could probably do it in a few years. And I'd, yeah, sure. Doctor, fine, whatever. You know what I mean, those are extreme examples. But programming language, yeah, I could learn that programming language, right? Every single thing that you could possibly throw at them, they're like, yeah, I could do that. There's no reason why I couldn't do that. I could learn that. And it's because they have that ability. They've taught themselves how to teach themselves, honestly. And so I would say that's really the most valuable thing. Yeah, that makes sense. I mean, I always find it kind of interesting
我可以成为一名律师。我可能几年内就能做到。而且我，是的，当然。医生，没问题，随便什么。你知道我的意思，那些是极端的例子。但是编程语言，是的，我可以学习那种编程语言，对吧？你能扔给他们的每一件事，他们都说，是的，我能做到。没有理由我做不到。我可以学习那个。这是因为他们有那种能力。老实说，他们已经学会了如何自学。所以我认为那真的是最有价值的事情。是的，这很有道理。我的意思是，我总是觉得很有趣
when there are jobs that, you know, I mean, there might be a job that's, you know, building the Java virtual machine for Oracle. Well, I'm sure you need to be a Java expert, right? But there's so many jobs where they're building a website and they say, you know, need to know java and and i bet if you went there and you said you know look i have never done java i've done php but i could probably pick it up in a couple of weeks i mean they would at least give you an interview um and
当有一些工作，你知道，我的意思是，可能有一份工作是，你知道，为Oracle构建Java虚拟机。嗯，我相信你需要成为一名Java专家，对吧？但有太多的工作是他们正在构建一个网站，他们说，你知道，需要懂Java，我敢打赌，如果你去那里说，你知道，看，我从来没做过Java，我做过PHP，但我可能在几周内就能学会，我的意思是，他们至少会给你一个面试机会，嗯，而且
so i think uh yeah a lot of it is as you said it's sort of knowing that that you're much more malleable than you think that that you can learn anything and being able to project that um to other people i think is super important so what about let's say there's a college student you know cs grad has all the technical background uh you know but but uh someone like like like patrick or myself in in college you know i only worked my first job i was uh doing taekwondo i taught taek my first job I was doing Taekwondo. I taught Taekwondo. And then I did Taekwondo in the Mulan parade at Disney.
所以我认为，嗯，是的，很多正如你所说，这是一种知道你比你想象的要灵活得多，你可以学习任何东西，并且能够向其他人展示这一点，我认为这超级重要。那么，假设有一个大学生，你知道，CS毕业生，有所有的技术背景，嗯，你知道，但，嗯，像帕特里克或我自己在大学里，你知道，我只做了我的第一份工作，我当时，嗯，在做跆拳道，我教跆拳道，我的第一份工作我是在做跆拳道。我教跆拳道。然后我在迪士尼的花木兰游行中表演了跆拳道。
So I would just break boards. I'd pretend to be a Chinese Mulan soldier, right? And so you get college students who have, they have all the technical background, but from the workforce, they're experiencing the workforce background, but, you know, from the workforce, they've just been, their experience in the workforce is, you know, selling popcorn, right? So what's the best advice you could kind of give them to get started in industry? So, I mean, I think there's a few ways to look at this, right?
所以我只是劈木板。我假装自己是一名中国花木兰士兵，对吧？所以你会遇到有技术背景的大学生，但从劳动力市场来看，他们正在经历劳动力市场背景，但，你知道，从劳动力市场来看，他们只是，他们在劳动力市场的经验是，你知道，卖爆米花，对吧？所以你能给他们的最好的建议是什么，让他们开始进入行业？所以，我的意思是，我认为有几种看待这个问题的方法，对吧？
So the advice I'm giving most young developers now or want to be developers is to to to really go out on your own and figure out i mean it depends on which path you want to go but there's opportunity now to like don't go into debt don't get shackled with a big car payment and house payment like figure out how to limit your means as much as possible because that's that's how you gain freedom right so i would say that from the bigger perspective, I always talk about the idea that you've got this mortgage on your life, right? And we're all born with a mortgage on our life. And as soon as we have enough income that we can pay all of our upkeep costs, right, then we're free. We have have freedom we can do whatever we want
所以我现在给大多数年轻开发人员或想成为开发人员的人的建议是，真正去走自己的路，弄清楚，我的意思是，这取决于你想走哪条路，但现在有机会，比如不要负债，不要被沉重的车贷和房贷束缚，尽可能弄清楚如何限制你的开支，因为那就是你获得自由的方式，对吧？所以我从更大的角度来说，我总是谈论这样一个观点，即你的生活背负着抵押贷款，对吧？我们每个人生来就背负着生活的抵押贷款。一旦我们有足够的收入来支付我们所有的生活成本，对吧，那么我们就自由了。我们拥有自由，我们可以做任何我们想做的事
essentially right and so i would i would i would say that if that appeals to you think about that like you could do that now as far as like the more traditional route of going you say no john i i really couldn't care i want to i want to make a six-figure developer salary. Okay, well, then my advice would be a little bit different, which would be essentially don't assume that you have to do everything whatever the dice or whatever the job search boards are and apply for 500 jobs with the same resume and cover letter and then hope that some people call you back and get interviews. That's not it. If you're going to do that, you could do the numbers game. If you're going to do the numbers game, then I would say,
本质上，对吧？所以我，我会说，如果这吸引你，考虑一下，就像你现在就可以这样做。至于像走传统路线，你说不，约翰，我真的不在乎，我想，我想赚六位数的开发人员薪水。好吧，那么我的建议会有点不同，本质上就是不要假设你必须做任何事情，无论骰子或求职网站上有什么，然后用同样的简历和求职信申请500份工作，然后希望有些人给你回电并获得面试机会。那不是这样的。如果你要那样做，你可以玩数字游戏。如果你要玩数字游戏，那么我会说，
hey, treat it like a sales funnel and measure the metrics. And I've got some sections on my new book on how exactly to do that. But I honestly would rather see young people figuring out out just get some – build up your network that way. What about going and what about you got a company you really want to work for? What about building a tool for that company, right? That makes, you know, some product that they're using more efficient or that improves their website in some way or, you know, something where they're going to hire you because you did something that's actually value. You immediately have value from the beginning. You know, what about What about doing what a lot of really successful salespeople do and calling the CEO of the company and just asking his secretary to put you through to him and talk to him and just saying, hey, I'm a software developer. I'm a new developer.
嘿，把它当作一个销售漏斗，衡量指标。我的新书里有一些章节专门讲如何做到这一点。但我老实说，我宁愿看到年轻人弄清楚，只是得到一些——通过那种方式建立你的网络。去，如果你有一家你真正想工作的公司怎么办？为那家公司构建一个工具，对吧？这使得，你知道，他们正在使用的某种产品更高效，或者以某种方式改进了他们的网站，或者，你知道，做一些事情，他们会雇佣你，因为你做了一些真正有价值的事情。你从一开始就立即有了价值。你知道，关于，关于做很多非常成功的销售人员所做的事情，给公司CEO打电话，只是让他的秘书把你转接给他，和他谈谈，只是说，嘿，我是一名软件开发人员。我是一名新开发人员。
I wanted to just, if I could listen, get five minutes of your time and pitch it. I mean, there's five minutes of your time and pitch it, right? I mean, there's a lot of ways. I'm throwing out some crazy stuff here because so many people think that what they have to do is they have to put in their resume and they have to go through HR and they have to have these keywords and then they go to the interview. And it's not like that at all. I mean, some of the best jobs I ever got were jobs where someone called me up and said, hey, come work for us, right? Yeah, that makes sense. I think it definitely is something that, yeah, I think to extend on that, like don't think your first job is going to be your whole life. I mean, like my father worked the same job his whole career. My father my, my father worked the same job, his whole career,
我只是想，如果我可以听听，占用你五分钟时间并推销一下。我的意思是，占用你五分钟时间并推销一下，对吧？我的意思是，有很多方法。我在这里抛出一些疯狂的东西，因为太多人认为他们必须做的是，他们必须提交简历，他们必须通过人力资源部门，他们必须有这些关键词，然后他们去面试。根本不是那样的。我的意思是，我得到的一些最好的工作是有人打电话给我说，嘿，来为我们工作，对吧？是的，这很有道理。我认为这绝对是，是的，我认为延伸一下，不要认为你的第一份工作就是你的全部生活。我的意思是，就像我父亲整个职业生涯都做同一份工作。我父亲，我，我父亲整个职业生涯都做同一份工作，
my father-in-law worked the same job for, I think, 50 years. Um, but now things have kind of changed, especially in our field. And, uh, it doesn't mean you should really go into your first job saying, oh, I, you know, I'm my, my, my, my goal is to get out of this job. Right. But but, you know, you kind of go into it, you know, wanting to think of it as a bank where, you know, you want to deposit a lot of your effort and time. But you also want that deposit to mature and to grow and get interest. Right. And you want to be able to withdraw more than you put in. And through building the right connections and through developing some of these soft skills, also developing some of the technical skills as well, through all of that, you can either advance in that job or if you find one that's better later on, you can switch and you can hopefully switch with having gained some interest on that.
我岳父做了同一份工作，我想，50年。嗯，但现在情况有点变了，尤其是在我们这个领域。而且，嗯，这并不意味着你应该真的带着“哦，我，你知道，我的目标是离开这份工作”的想法去开始你的第一份工作。对吧？但，但，你知道，你进入它时，你知道，想把它当作一个银行，你知道，你想存入你大量的努力和时间。但你也希望那笔存款成熟并增长并获得利息。对吧？你希望能够提取比你存入的更多的钱。通过建立正确的联系和通过发展一些这些软技能，同时也发展一些技术技能，通过所有这些，你可以在那份工作中晋升，或者如果你以后发现一份更好的工作，你可以跳槽，并且希望你能带着从那笔存款中获得的利息跳槽。
Yeah, yeah, I totally agree. It's all about that long-term perspective, right? Because you realize that you're not probably going to be there forever. And times have changed. It really has changed. You know, a lot of times, in fact, what I found is that a lot of times today, the only way to make an advancement in your career is to switch, is to move. It used to be frowned upon to job hop.
是的，是的，我完全同意。这完全是关于那种长期的视角，对吧？因为你意识到你可能不会永远待在那里。时代变了。它真的变了。你知道，很多时候，事实上，我发现的是，很多时候今天，在你的职业生涯中取得进步的唯一方法是跳槽，是移动。过去，跳槽是不被看好的。
Not saying that you should switch jobs every six months, but every couple of years, that is not necessarily a bad idea. Sometimes that's the best way to scale up the ladder. Yeah, and again's it's one of these things that should be natural right i mean you can't go into it saying yeah in two years i'm going to either get a promotion or be somewhere else it's more just yeah as i said before you're depositing this this time and this effort but you're also kind of being self-aware and and uh if if that opportunity if an opportunity comes up there's going to be a chance that the opportunity will be in your current job. But there's also going to be a chance, probably a much greater
不是说你应该每六个月换一次工作，但每隔几年，这不一定是个坏主意。有时这是攀登阶梯的最好方法。是的，这又是那种应该是自然而然的事情，对吧？我的意思是，你不能带着“是的，两年后我要么升职要么去别的地方”的想法去开始。这更多只是，正如我之前所说，你正在存入这段时间和这份努力，但你也在保持自我意识，而且，嗯，如果，如果机会出现了，机会将出现在你当前工作中的可能性是有的。但也有可能，可能更大
chance, that that opportunity is going to be somewhere else in this very large world, right? And so, you know, it's important to make sure that you sort of honor your obligation. You can't just leave after six months. I mean, they're hiring you because they want to ramp you up and then you have to put in that deposit, right? Otherwise, you're not going to withdraw anything. Right. Yeah, but I think the self-awareness is extremely important. What about, so we have a lot of people listen to the show who, they're kind of on the other side of the fence.
的机会是，那个机会将出现在这个非常广阔的世界的其他地方，对吧？所以，你知道，确保你履行你的义务很重要。你不能在六个月后就离开。我的意思是，他们雇佣你是为了让你上手，然后你必须投入那笔存款，对吧？否则，你什么也取不出来。对吧。是的，但我认为自我意识极其重要。那么，我们有很多听众，他们，他们有点在围栏的另一边。
So they might have incredibly good soft skills. They also have an incredible ability in some area, let's say biology or chemistry, or maybe they are a carpenter or they have sort of a discipline and they have put many years into that and now they want to switch. They want to go into CS, right? And so they have the industry experience,
所以他们可能有非常好的软技能。他们在某个领域也有令人难以置信的能力，比如说生物学或化学，或者也许他们是木匠，或者他们有某种纪律，并且在其中投入了多年，现在他们想转行。他们想进入CS，对吧？所以他们有行业经验，
but they're kind of transitioning to a brand new field, right? And so they're kind of in a different boat than the college student. What kind of advice would you give them those are my favorite developers first of all the best developers i've ever met and worked with have always been those kind of people that amazingly that you know after a career 20 years as a biologist or there's a guy i worked with i was an environmentalist of some sort and And then they become a developer. And in the short three years that they're a developer, it's like they have 10 or 15 years of experience. And I haven't really been able to.
但他们有点在向一个全新的领域过渡，对吧？所以他们和大学生处于不同的境地。你会给他们什么建议？首先，那些是我最喜欢的开发人员。我见过和共事过的最好的开发人员总是那些人，令人惊讶的是，你知道，在作为生物学家工作20年后，或者有一个我和他共事过的人，是一个某种环保主义者，然后他们成为了一名开发人员。在他们成为开发人员的短短三年里，就像他们有10或15年的经验一样。我真的没能。
It was a strange phenomenon that eluded me for such a long time but what i think about this is that when you achieve a mastery level in one skill it a lot even this stuff that doesn't seem like it carries over it carries over it carries over because you've you've maybe it's just the time and the dedication and the grit that you've developed in in becoming a master at something or but but it does it really does and so what i would say to them is that they have a distinct advantage for multiple reasons. One, because if you've already been successful at one thing, I mean, and you see this all the time, you see people, you, you see people that are super successful in multiple areas, right? Because it's success begets success. And so what I would say to them is, you know, you have an advantage because of that,
这是一个奇怪的现象，困扰了我很长一段时间，但我认为关于这一点是，当你在一项技能上达到精通水平时，它，很多即使看起来不相关的东西，它也会迁移，它会迁移，因为它，你，也许只是你在成为某事的大师过程中培养的时间、奉献精神和毅力，或者，但它确实，它真的会。所以我对他们说的是，他们因为多种原因具有明显的优势。第一，因为如果你已经在某件事上取得了成功，我的意思是，你一直看到这一点，你看到人们，你，你看到人们在多个领域都超级成功，对吧？因为成功孕育成功。所以我对他们说的是，你知道，因为这一点你有一个优势，
so it's going to be easier for you, right, than most people. And then second, you've got another perspective that is extremely valuable, right? Not coming from the whole, you know, sometimes we can be cynical and jaded in the software development community. We don't see things because we're too much in the water. We're too much in the thick of it and everyone has the same opinions. And so bringing in those outside opinions, seeing things from a different perspective is really awesome and is very valuable. And you end up making a really valuable member of the team because you have that perspective. So I would say that it seems overwhelming, right? There's a lot of stuff to learn. And yes, there is a lot in software development.
所以它对你来说会比大多数人更容易，对吧？然后第二，你有另一个非常有价值的视角，对吧？不是来自整个，你知道，有时我们在软件开发社区中会变得愤世嫉俗和厌倦。我们看不到事物，因为我们太沉浸其中了。我们太深陷其中，每个人都有相同的观点。所以引入那些外部观点，从不同的角度看问题真的很棒，而且非常有价值。你最终会成为团队中非常有价值的一员，因为你有那种视角。所以我认为这看起来让人不知所措，对吧？有很多东西要学。是的，软件开发中确实有很多东西。
And yes, it can take you years and years to achieve what you're never going to totally master. And technology completely changes. But have a little bit more confidence than you might have and dive in and, you know, pick. And the key thing, especially when you don't have 20 years of career, maybe laughter or whatever, is that you be very specific about what it is you want to do and what you want to learn, right? But within software development, there's so many things. There's so many technologies and programming languages. I mean, you could spend your entire life learning JavaScript frameworks, I'm pretty sure. Yeah. And it would be a treadmill that you'd just be slipping backwards on. So rather than trying to learn everything and trying to know a little bit about everything, be very, very specific. Say, you know, I'm going to be a mean stack developer.
是的，这可能需要你花费多年时间才能达到你永远无法完全精通的程度。而且技术完全改变了。但要比你可能有的多一点自信，潜入其中，并且，你知道，选择。关键的事情，特别是当你没有20年的职业生涯，也许是笑声或其他什么时，是你对你想做什么和你想学什么要非常具体，对吧？但在软件开发中，有很多事情。有很多技术和编程语言。我的意思是，我敢肯定，你可以花一辈子时间学习JavaScript框架。是的。那将是一台你只会向后滑的跑步机。所以与其试图学习一切并试图对每件事都了解一点，不如非常、非常具体。说，你知道，我将成为一名MEAN栈开发人员。
Good. Learn everything in that if you're going to do full set right or be very you know pick a specialty be very specific pick exactly the skill set that you need to to learn in order to do that and be functional then you can fill in the gaps and the other stuff later you know you'll eventually need to to you'll eventually do better if you do pick up that CS background that a lot of CS students have, but they forgot anyway. You need to know. If you know the algorithms and data structures, it is actually pretty valuable, but don't start with that stuff. That's not going to help you immediately.
很好。如果你要进行全栈开发，就学习其中的一切，或者非常，你知道，选择一个专业，非常具体。选择你为了做到这一点而需要学习的精确技能集，并且能够发挥作用，然后你以后可以填补空白和其他东西，你知道，如果你确实掌握了许多CS学生拥有的CS背景，你会做得更好，但他们反正也忘了。你需要知道。如果你知道算法和数据结构，它实际上相当有价值，但不要从那些东西开始。那不会立即帮助你。
And you won't see the value of it until you're actually working as a functional software developer this is why our colleges are so messed up is today in the way that we teach developers is because we start with the basic cs stuff which which you don't understand the value of until you're actually working as a developer for a couple years and then you go back and like oh yeah oh okay man now that makes sense like using that hash that That's why I would use that, right? And so then the stuff sticks. So I would say, you know, just jump in, but be very specific about what you're jumping into so that you cut that down. It can be overwhelming with all this stuff out there, but you don't have to know it all and no one can know it all. Even veteran developers that have been around for 20 years, trust me, they don't know it all
而且在你真正作为一名功能性软件开发人员工作之前，你不会看到它的价值。这就是为什么我们的大学如此混乱，今天我们教开发人员的方式是因为我们从基础的CS东西开始，在你真正作为开发人员工作几年之前，你并不理解它的价值，然后你回去，就像“哦，是的，哦，好吧，伙计，现在这有道理了”，使用那个哈希，这就是为什么我会使用那个，对吧？所以东西就记住了。所以我说，你知道，只是跳进去，但要对你跳进去的东西非常具体，这样你就可以减少它。外面有这么多东西可能会让人不知所措，但你不必全都知道，也没有人能全都知道。即使是已经存在20年的资深开发人员，相信我，他们也不知道全部
they know a very small fraction of it but that's all you need we're in a field where there are 5,000 tools 5,000 different kinds of hammers and you only need to know how to use one of those hammers
他们只知道其中很小的一部分，但这正是你所需要的。我们处于一个有5000种工具、5000种不同锤子的领域，你只需要知道如何使用其中一把锤子
and you can hit your nails you've got to have a few more tools in your tool belt but don't feel like you have to know all this stuff yeah that makes sense that's some kind of like beam search where basically you know i think if you if you don't have a background in cs and you don't have the degree then um people aren't going to give you the same sort of um cushion that they'll give someone with a CS degree. I mean, I know people who have a CS degree. I mean, I'm almost guilty of this myself, where it's all purely theoretical.
你就可以钉钉子了，你的工具带里需要多几把工具，但不要觉得你必须知道所有这些东西。是的，这很有道理。这有点像波束搜索，基本上，你知道，我认为如果你没有CS背景，也没有学位，那么，人们不会给你像给CS学位的人那样的缓冲。我的意思是，我认识有CS学位的人。我的意思是，我自己几乎也有罪，这完全是理论上的。
And some of us have done coding, had done coding on the side. But I know some people who, you know, their CS degree was totally off the chalkboard. And those people are afforded a cushion when they interview and things like that, because people know that they spent a lot of time on this theoretical. And they're expecting to companies are expecting to have to kind of pay a price up front, having to ramp this person up on, you know, C++ or something. But in exchange, I'll get someone who has sort of a good growth in the tail, like in the future. If you don't have a CS degree, then it's going to be hard to get a company that gives you the same sort of cushion. But that's where, as John said, you can kind of be really specific and become kind of really proficient in one thing, get that first job. And then and then you can really broaden your horizons then and look at sort of how that
我们中的一些人做过编码，在业余时间做过编码。但我认识一些人，你知道，他们的CS学位完全是脱离实际的。这些人面试时会得到缓冲，诸如此类，因为人们知道他们花了很多时间在这些理论上。他们期望公司期望不得不预先付出代价，不得不让这个人上手C++之类的。但作为交换，我会得到一个在未来有良好增长的人。如果你没有CS学位，那么很难找到一家给你同样缓冲的公司。但这就是约翰所说的，你可以变得非常具体，在某件事上变得非常精通，得到第一份工作。然后，然后你真的可以拓宽你的视野，看看那种
thing you learned fits into the bigger picture and all of that. What about what do you think about, you know, we get a lot of emails that are sort of, you know, should i go back to college or should i do this boot camp and um patrick and i we interviewed uh um art gill up gillis epi from uh udacity a few months ago and udacity is a pretty cool program um but in general we haven't at least patrick and i haven't seen a lot of people um you know in the places we've worked or or in our context like uh who have come from sort of these kind of boot camp environments most people are either self-taught or from university and so we're kind of torn
你学到的东西如何融入更大的图景等等。那么你觉得，你知道，我们收到很多电子邮件，都是那种，你知道，我应该回大学还是应该参加这个训练营，嗯，帕特里克和我，我们几个月前采访了来自Udacity的Art Gillis Epi，Udacity是一个很酷的项目，但总的来说，我们至少帕特里克和我没有看到很多人，你知道，在我们工作的地方或者在我们的背景中，谁来自这种训练营环境，大多数人要么是自学的，要么来自大学，所以我们有点纠结
because on one hand something like udacityera, these kind of things are kind of revolutionary, and I'd love for MOOCs like this to succeed, but on the other hand, it really kind of hasn't happened yet. And I feel like you will probably have a broader vision than Patrick and I, who we basically live, I don't know, five miles away from each other. So what do you think, in kind of a more holistic way, do you feel like these of a more holistic way, do you feel like these boot camp classes are valuable?
因为一方面，像Udacityera这样的东西是革命性的，我希望像这样的MOOC能够成功，但另一方面，它真的还没有发生。我觉得你可能比帕特里克和我更有广阔的视野，我们基本上住在一起，我不知道，离彼此五英里远。所以你觉得，以一种更全面的方式，你觉得这些训练营课程有价值吗？
Are they a scam? Are they somewhere in between? Is there a huge variance? What's kind of the landscape like? That's a great question. This is a question I get all the time. In fact, the new book that I'm putting out, I put like the very first portion of the book is like, should I go to college? Should I go to bootcamp? Should I self-teach? Right. Because it's such a critical
它们是骗局吗？它们介于两者之间吗？有巨大的差异吗？景观是什么样的？这是一个很好的问题。这是我一直被问到的问题。事实上，我正在出的新书，我把书的第一部分写成了，我应该上大学吗？我应该去训练营吗？我应该自学吗？对吧。因为它是一个如此关键的
question. And then, and then how did it succeed at each one of those? But here's the thing. I'm very bullish on bootcamp as a choice based on, on a couple of parameters that, that, that I have to set up front. First of all, it's, it's based on, I think that it's the best bang for your buck if you do it right. And it just makes sense to me today, right? Like I'd rather, if I were starting out today, I wouldn't even go the self-taught route simply because it takes more time
问题。然后，然后如何在每一个中取得成功？但事情是这样的。我非常看好训练营作为一个选择，基于我必须预先设定的几个参数。首先，它是，我认为如果你做对了，它是性价比最高的。而且它在今天对我来说很有意义，对吧？就像我宁愿，如果我今天开始，我甚至不会走自学路线，仅仅因为它需要更多时间
and it's harder to figure out what you need to know, right? If someone can give me, you know, a a really intensive, I think of an immersion program and just get me working as soon as possible, that's great because then I can start. That's the beginning of my education, but I can get paid while I'm getting my education the rest of the way. I think that that is definitely the promise of boot camp. Now, in reality, does this happen? So in reality, what we're faced with is a landmine of there's some crappy boot camps, of course, right? It's hard to judge the level of some of the boot camps. And it's sort of in between, right?
而且很难弄清楚你需要知道什么，对吧？如果有人能给我，你知道，一个非常密集的，我想是一个沉浸式项目，并让我尽快开始工作，那太好了，因为那样我就可以开始了。那是我的教育的开始，但我可以在完成剩余教育的同时获得报酬。我认为这绝对是训练营的承诺。现在，在现实中，这会发生吗？所以在现实中，我们面临的是一个地雷阵，当然有一些糟糕的训练营，对吧？很难判断一些训练营的水平。它介于两者之间，对吧？
College, you go to college, they tell you what to do, right? Like it's completely tell you what to do, right? Boot camp, they're giving you the instruction, but it's it's completely tell you what to do, right? Bootcamp is they're, they're giving you, but they're giving you the instruction, but it's sort of really very much up to you, right? I mean, you've got this time and you can decide how you're going to use that time. Like, are you really going to hunker down and learn what you need to learn? And then, you know, for, for self-instruction, it's, if you need some kind of structure, self-instruction, I mean mean I know a lot of developers that have been self-instructing for four or five years and they haven't even created a resume or applied for any jobs. So it can be an issue.
大学，你去大学，他们告诉你该做什么，对吧？就像它完全告诉你该做什么，对吧？训练营，他们给你指导，但它完全告诉你该做什么，对吧？训练营是他们，他们给你，但他们给你指导，但它在很大程度上取决于你，对吧？我的意思是，你有这段时间，你可以决定你将如何利用这段时间。就像，你真的要沉下心来学习你需要学习的东西吗？然后，你知道，对于自学，如果需要某种结构，自学，我的意思是，我知道很多开发人员已经自学了四五年，他们甚至没有创建简历或申请任何工作。所以这可能是一个问题。
But what I'd say with Bootcamp is this. First of all, don't – okay, it's a very cheap alternative, right? So the advantage of boot camp is, like I said, it's short learning curve, getting you a job very quickly, and the investment is relatively small. So don't cheap out, right? If you're going to do a boot camp, don't price shop the boot camps. Go and pick a quality boot camp where people have graduated and gotten, they have a high placement rate, and then go and call the references and check and see. Okay. So that'd be my first piece of advice. Then the second thing I would say
但我对训练营要说的是这个。首先，不要——好吧，这是一个非常便宜的替代方案，对吧？所以训练营的优势是，就像我说的，学习曲线短，让你很快找到工作，而且投资相对较小。所以不要吝啬，对吧？如果你要参加训练营，不要去比价训练营。去选择一个高质量的训练营，那里的人已经毕业并获得了，他们有很高的安置率，然后去给推荐人打电话，检查看看。好吧。所以那将是我给出的第一个建议。然后我要说的第二件事
is that here's the thing, as long as it's a decent bootcamp, if you think of it this way, okay, if you're the top person in the class, let's say it's a three month program in that bootcamp. If you're the top person, do you think you'll get a job? Right? Probably. And you'll probably get a good one, right? I mean, any bootcamp, a bootcamp would be really, really crappy if the best person in the bootcamp didn't get a job. Their homepage would look so sad, right? I mean, their homepage would be, look at Jim, you know, he's on the street. Exactly, right? So you've got to assume. So I would assume that the top 10% of people in a particular class are going to almost have like a 90% chance of getting a job.
关键在于，只要是一个像样的训练营，如果你这样想：假设你是班里最顶尖的学生，比如这是一个为期三个月的项目。如果你是第一名，你觉得你能找到工作吗？对吧？很有可能。而且你很可能会找到一份不错的工作，对吧？我的意思是，如果训练营里最优秀的人都找不到工作，那这个训练营也太烂了。他们的主页看起来会很惨，对吧？我的意思是，他们的主页会写着：“看看吉姆，他现在流落街头。”确实如此，对吧？所以你得假设。我会认为，班里前10%的学生几乎有90%的机会找到工作。
If you've filtered okay, right? I mean, and that's a pretty conservative estimate. But if I'm going to a boot camp, this is my objective. I am going to be the number one person. I'm going to bootcamp, this is my objective. I am going to be the number one person. I'm going to work harder than anyone else. I'm going to apply myself more than anyone else. If it's within my ability, I am going to, and especially it's an intensive program, right? You're doing this for three months, like a full-time job or more, you know, 10, 12 hours a day, freaking bring it all, go all in on this and, and be, because,
前提是你筛选得当，对吧？我的意思是，这还是一个相当保守的估计。但如果我要去参加训练营，这就是我的目标。我要成为第一名。我要去训练营，这就是我的目标。我要成为第一名。我要比任何人都努力。我要比任何人都投入。如果我能做到，我一定会去做，尤其是这是一个高强度的项目，对吧？你要全职甚至更投入地做三个月，每天10到12个小时，全力以赴，全身心投入，因为，
and this is why I'm saying this is because I feel like if you, if you take some basic steps, right, if you filter and make sure that you've got at least a semi-quality boot camp, right. And you are aiming at being in the top, top one, but let's say top five or top 10% of the, of the boot camp realistically, because there might be some genius. You might have, what's his name, Doogie Howser in there, and he might just whoop the pants off you no matter what you do. But if you're aiming for the number one slot, you're almost guaranteed success. I mean, this is so much the truth in life in general, right?
我之所以这么说，是因为我觉得如果你采取一些基本步骤，进行筛选并确保你参加的是一个质量尚可的训练营，并且你的目标是成为前1%，或者现实一点，前5%或前10%的学生，因为班里可能会有天才。你可能会遇到像“天才小医生”那样的人，无论你怎么努力，他都可能把你甩在身后。但如果你以第一名为目标，你几乎就锁定了成功。我的意思是，这在生活中也是如此，对吧？
But this is how I would hack the boot camp, right? In my mind, I'm thinking there's no way you fail. If you take this approach, what, what, what, where you fail is when you take the half-ass approach, when you're like this, when you're like, Oh gee, gee, Bob, I I'd like to get a software developer job. Cause those guys make a lot of, a lot of freaking money. My, my, my friend Joe has a software developer job. So, Hmm, what should I do? Should I learn on my own, like do some courses online? Nah, college, I don't want to really spend four years. Oh, there's a boot camp for eight weeks. I'm going to sign up for this boot camp. And they said, they'll get me ready
但这就是我破解训练营的方法，对吧？在我看来，你不可能失败。如果你采取这种方法，你会失败是因为你采取了敷衍了事的态度，当你表现得像这样：“哦，鲍勃，我想找一份软件开发的工作。因为那些人赚很多钱。我的朋友乔有一份软件开发的工作。所以，嗯，我该怎么办？我是该自学，还是在网上上些课程？不，大学，我不想花四年时间。哦，有一个为期八周的训练营。我要报名参加这个训练营。他们说，他们会让我准备好，”
and get me a job. If that's your attitude and you go in and you think that somehow magically you're going to go into this program and then eight weeks later, you're going to get a six figure developer job. No, sorry. It's not going to happen but if you're like man i really want to become a developer and i'm willing to do what it takes and i'm i'm learning on my own as much as i can in preparation for this boot camp i'm going to sign up for this thing and i'm going to put my all in it i'm going to stay after i'm going to tutor other people in the class i'm going to get as much help as i can and see if i can help the instructor right i'm going to really devote my life to this and try to be the top person in this class. Yeah, I don't see how you could possibly fail if you have the second attitude. But the first one, you know, is guaranteed
“并帮我找到工作。”如果这是你的态度，你认为自己能神奇地进入这个项目，八周后就能得到一份六位数的开发工作。不，抱歉。那是不可能的。但如果你是那种“伙计，我真的想成为一名开发人员，我愿意付出一切，我在为这个训练营做准备时尽可能多地自学，我要报名参加，我要全力以赴，我要留下来加班，我要辅导班里的其他人，我要尽可能多地寻求帮助，看看我能否帮助讲师，”我真的会把我的生活投入到这上面，并努力成为班里最顶尖的人。是的，如果你有第二种态度，我看不出你怎么会失败。但第一种态度，你知道，几乎注定会失败。
failure almost. I agree with most of that. I was having this conversation with someone at work as well. And I have a couple additional heuristics but i you know i don't know because i think it's still a little bit early but one of them is finding a place that has teachers the instructors that work or have worked at jobs you would want oh that's a good point so if you you know so here we're in the san francisco silicon valley you know if you want to work at uber find a boot camp that has instructors that came from Uber. A couple reasons. One is because they'll help you with what you need to be able to do to get a job there.
我同意大部分观点。我在工作中也和别人讨论过这个问题。我还有几个额外的启发式方法，但我不知道，因为我觉得现在说还为时过早。其中之一是找一个有老师的地方，那些讲师正在或曾经在你想去的公司工作过。哦，那是个好观点。所以，如果你在旧金山硅谷，如果你想在Uber工作，就找一个有来自Uber的讲师的训练营。原因有二。一是他们会帮你掌握在那里工作所需的能力。
And the second one is because they have a network or either are still there. And that can definitely help with placement of, like we were already talking about, the top people. The best people are going to get the referrals and they're going to refer people because that helps them and it's a it's a self-fulfilling thing like if they refer the best people it increases the their you know instructor aptitude it increases the college like everything at the boot camp everything gets better so that's one and the second one is sort of similar which is do a boot camp if possible in an area you would like to have the job for for basically the same reasons so if you want to work in the silicon valley my advice would be to find a boot camp in silicon valley because you're going to have peers graduating and instructors that have connections in that area
第二个原因是他们有人脉，或者他们本人还在那里工作。这绝对有助于安置，就像我们刚才说的，那些顶尖人才。最优秀的人会得到推荐，他们也会推荐别人，因为这对他自己也有帮助，这是一个自我实现的循环。如果他们推荐最优秀的人，这会提升他们作为讲师的能力，提升训练营的整体水平，一切都会变得更好。所以这是一个原因。第二个原因类似，如果可能的话，在你想工作的地区参加训练营，原因基本相同。所以如果你想在硅谷工作，我的建议是找一个硅谷的训练营，因为你会有在那一地区有关系的同学和讲师。
if you do one and i don't know where all the you know large bootcamps are but if you do one in florida hoping to get a job in california it can happen but it you know you're just not helping your odds yeah that's a good point um yeah that's really good points yeah yeah the other i mean i so you know i get like my i have a like huge like uh uh bias in this because you know my grandfather's a math professor, his father's a math professor. My dad's was a, was a engineer. And so, so, uh, um, like a ton of academic sort of people in my family. And so I'm always in the mindset, you know, go to college, but, but, uh, but the, the thing that, that I, I totally, uh, uh uh uh believes that college gives you the the the lower bar in other words you can get a degree and be like let's say incompetent and you have that diploma
如果你参加了一个训练营，我不知道所有大型训练营都在哪，但如果你在佛罗里达参加，却希望在加州找工作，这虽然可能发生，但你并没有增加自己的胜算。是的，那是个好观点。嗯，是的，这些观点真的很好。是的，另外，我在这方面有很大的偏见，因为我祖父是数学教授，他父亲也是数学教授。我父亲是一名工程师。所以，我家里有很多学术型的人。所以我总是那种心态，去上大学，但我完全相信大学为你提供了一个底线，换句话说，你可以拿到学位，即使你能力不足，你也有那个文凭。
so like it will take the worst people and bring them up but college won't necessarily take the best people and and give them the best possible experience right so um you know i think it's sort of a toss-up i mean i think if you already went to college for biology let's say it's probably not a good idea to go back through another four years to get a cs degree that's that's something i agree with um but either way yeah i think the goal should be to be the best. And this is true, even if you want to be any career, like, like, uh, I feel like anything I say, I will disparage that career. So I'm not going to pick anything up, but no matter what you want to be is, is, is, is, uh, the goal is to, yeah, go into it, looking, look at the best people in that career
所以它会把最差的人拉上来，但大学不一定会把最优秀的人培养到极致，对吧？所以，嗯，我认为这很难说。我的意思是，如果你已经读了生物学大学，再去花四年时间拿一个计算机科学学位可能不是个好主意，这一点我同意。但无论如何，我认为目标应该是成为最优秀的。这在任何职业中都是如此，我觉得我说的任何话都可能贬低那个职业。所以我不会选具体的例子，但无论你想成为什么，目标都是进入那个领域，看看那个领域里最优秀的人，
and, and you should want to be, uh to be uh to have the same sort of career experiences as those people um and that that should be kind of your target like if you want to be a basketball player you know when people who want i actually went to basketball camp uh when i was in high school i was terrible at basketball um but i went to basketball camp and uh there were people who said, you know, I want to be like Shaq or I want to be like Anthony Hardaway, who is popular at the time. And they had sort of role models and they had kind of targets and they had sort of respect for that. I feel like it's the same kind of thing where know what it means to be the best person at
你应该想要拥有和他们一样的职业经历。那应该成为你的目标。比如如果你想成为一名篮球运动员，你知道，我高中时确实参加过篮球训练营，我篮球打得很烂，但我去了训练营，有些人说：“我想成为像奥尼尔那样的人，或者像安芬尼·哈达威那样的人，”当时他很受欢迎。他们有某种榜样，有某种目标，并且对此怀有敬意。我觉得这是同样的事情，知道成为最优秀的人意味着什么，
whether it's your university or your boot camp class or what have you, and then strive to sort of be better than that person, right? Exactly. Yeah, you're dead on. It's funny. I was talking with a friend of mine, and he was talking about his kid being in Little League and how the kid was being benched all the time. And I told him, I said, there's a real simple solution to this rather than complain to the coach.
无论是在你的大学、训练营班级还是其他什么地方，然后努力去超越那个人，对吧？完全正确。是的，你说得太对了。很有趣。我和一个朋友聊天，他谈到他的孩子在小联盟打球，孩子总是坐冷板凳。我告诉他，我说，有一个非常简单的解决办法，而不是向教练抱怨。
So how many hours a day do the other kids practice? Right? And he's like, well, they just go to their practice, and I think some of their star players, you know, they'll do like an extra hour of practice every day. And I was like, tell your son, if he really wants to never be benched again, put in four hours of practice a day, three hours of practice, whatever it is. Whatever they're doing, do twice it. Guaranteed in six months or one season, guaranteed you'll
问问其他孩子每天练习多少小时？对吧？他说，他们只是去参加训练，我想他们的一些明星球员每天会多练习一小时。我说，告诉你的儿子，如果他真的想永远不再坐冷板凳，每天练习四个小时，三个小时，随便多少。无论别人在做什么，做两倍的量。保证六个月或一个赛季内，你肯定会成为首发。
be starting. You'll be so much better. Just do whatever the best person is doing and double it. Do better than whatever the best person is doing. Look at their training and do more of it. When I say it, it sounds so damn simple but it's one of those things that you get frustrated and you're like, I don't understand. I can never be like that but the answer is really it's putting on the overalls. That's it. Yeah, and I think one of the great sort of tragedies is, you know, I grew up in a part of my city where a lot of people played basketball and not a lot of people went into really engineering. And I found myself being really bad at that. I played basketball for years. I was terrible at it the whole time.
你会变得好得多。只要做最优秀的人正在做的事情，然后加倍。做得比最优秀的人更好。看看他们的训练，做得更多。当我这么说时，听起来很简单，但当你感到沮丧，觉得“我不明白，我永远无法像那样”时，答案其实就是穿上工装裤去干活。就是这样。是的，我认为一个巨大的悲剧是，我成长的城市里很多人打篮球，但很少有人从事工程行业。我发现自己在这方面真的很差。我打了很多年篮球，一直都很烂。
And in hindsight, i never really practiced like even i went to this camp i wasn't really actively participating and uh it just wasn't really my thing it wasn't really what i did for for fun um but then um you know the things i did do for fun like i did all sorts of like coding things. I did visits to Linux, like kernel hacking and things like that, and emulators. And these things, I ended up spending just an extraordinary amount of time on them. And the reality is, you know, there's people who are spending an unbelievable amount of time practicing, let's say, basketball. And there really aren't that many people who are spending that amount of time, you know, becoming the best JavaScript developer
事后看来，我从来没有真正练习过，即使我去了那个训练营，我也不是真的积极参与，那真的不是我的菜，不是我为了乐趣而做的事情。但后来，我为了乐趣而做的事情，比如我做了各种各样的编程。我访问过Linux内核黑客之类的东西，还有模拟器。这些事情，我最终在上面花费了极其大量的时间。现实情况是，有些人花费了难以置信的时间练习篮球。但真的没有多少人花费同样的时间成为最优秀的JavaScript开发人员。
or something like that. I mean, obviously there are people, but it's just not the same, let's say, ratio of people who are dedicating, let's say, 100 hours a week to JavaScript versus the number of jobs. That ratio is totally different than a number of people are dedicating, let's say, 100 hours a week to JavaScript versus the number of jobs, that ratio is totally different than the number of people who are dedicating 100 hours a week to football versus the number of football jobs, right? Oh, yeah. Yeah, so, I mean, you've got, it's an arbitrage situation, right?
或者类似的东西。我的意思是，显然有人在做，但比例不一样。比如，每周投入100小时学习JavaScript的人数与工作岗位数量的比例，与每周投入100小时练习足球的人数与足球工作岗位数量的比例完全不同，对吧？哦，是的。是的，所以，这是一种套利情况，对吧？
You've got a huge advantage. Like, the bar is actually pretty low, right? Like, if you wanted to become the best in the world at JavaScript, it's conceivable, if you wanted to become the best in the world at JavaScript, it's conceivable. If you want to be the best in the world at basketball, good luck. I mean, you know, right? As much as you practice. But you could do it at JavaScript.
你拥有巨大的优势。门槛其实很低，对吧？如果你想成为世界上最优秀的JavaScript开发者，这是可以想象的。如果你想成为世界上最优秀的篮球运动员，祝你好运。我的意思是，你知道，对吧？无论你练习多少。但你在JavaScript上可以做到。
Honestly, you could, right? You know, that's the bar is low there. You just have to be willing to do the work. I'm being so mean to JavaScript programmers. Poor JavaScript. Actually, somebody told me, I said, I was talking to somebody at work, and they said, oh, you know, you have a podcast. I'll follow you on Twitter.
老实说，你可以，对吧？你知道，那里的门槛很低。你只需要愿意付出努力。我对JavaScript程序员太刻薄了。可怜的JavaScript。其实有人告诉我，我和同事聊天时，他们说：“哦，你知道，你有播客。我会在Twitter上关注你。”
And so they followed me. So I looked up their profile, and they have something like 10,000 followers. And I said, how did you get so many followers on Twitter? And he said, dude, a javascript developer it's like all you have to do is be a javascript developer you get 20 times as many followers on twitter so i don't we give them a lot of hate but they're also probably the biggest community it's an it's absolutely astounding yeah it's funny i did a one of my more popular blog posts like for for a while i got i did this blog post on why javascript is is dead or doomed javascript is doomed and this was like you know
他们关注了我。我查看了他们的个人资料，他们有大约10,000名粉丝。我说，你是怎么在Twitter上获得这么多粉丝的？他说，伙计，JavaScript开发人员，你只需要成为一名JavaScript开发人员，你在Twitter上的粉丝数就会多出20倍。所以我不知道，我们给了他们很多仇恨，但他们也可能是最大的社区，这绝对令人震惊。是的，很有趣，我写过一篇比较受欢迎的博文，有一段时间我写了关于为什么JavaScript已死或注定失败的文章，JavaScript注定失败，那是在四五年前，它上了Hacker News的头版，我当时感觉糟透了，我躲在桌子底下哭，因为我收到了恶毒的评论。天哪。
four or five years ago and it went front page on hacker news and i was like the worst thing like i was crawling under my desk crying because the nasty comments I got. Oh, my gosh. And a stream and streams of them, like, for days. It was like, I hope you die. I will find your children and murder them. Well, if you want to hear worse comments, write such an article about any functional programming language.
成群结队的评论，持续了好几天。就像是，“我希望你死。我会找到你的孩子并杀了他们。”好吧，如果你想听更糟糕的评论，写一篇关于任何函数式编程语言的文章试试。
Oh, my gosh, yeah. Our Lisp show was unbelievable. Lisp is dead. Haskell is dead. Just pick any of them. Closure. We actually, you know,, our Lisp show was unbelievable. Lisp is dead, Haskell is dead, just pick any of them. Closure, Steam. We actually, you know, I learned Lisp, I don't know if it was my second language, but anyone who took intro to AI had to learn Lisp.
天哪，是的。我们的Lisp节目简直不可思议。Lisp已死。Haskell已死。随便挑一个。Closure。我们实际上，你知道，我学过Lisp，我不知道它是不是我的第二语言，但任何上过人工智能入门课的人都必须学习Lisp。
And so I was, you know, I was a Lisp sort of sympathizer. I didn't know that much about it, but I took the course and I liked it. And when Patrick and I did this show on lisp we got just unbelievable hate mail people are just like oh you don't understand it's really like this is you know you have to use this other expression and they've moved on for and it was just unbelievable it just never ended it's yeah it's funny it's it's funny how you know sometimes we get so religious about technology and stuff and it's Ultimately, it's like results. At the end of the day, the academic exercises are great.
所以我是一个Lisp的同情者。我不太了解它，但我上了那门课，我很喜欢它。当帕特里克和我做关于Lisp的节目时，我们收到了难以置信的仇恨邮件，人们只是说：“哦，你不懂，它实际上是这样的，你必须使用这种其他表达式，”他们已经转向了，这简直不可思议，没完没了。是的，很有趣，人们有时对技术变得如此狂热，最终，这就像结果一样。归根结底，学术练习很棒。
But ultimately, what is it you're actually accomplishing and doing? It's easy to get distracted and forget that that's the whole point. Yeah, that makes sense. The other part of it is to you know, uh, as you, uh, also is, is to keep a good network of people, right? Like for example, if you start to become the best JavaScript person in the world, then, then, uh, you're going to, let's say you seek out some people who you think are great at JavaScript and then you get so good, uh, or, you know, so much about the language that these people
但最终，你实际上在完成和做什么？很容易分心并忘记这才是重点。是的，这很有道理。另一部分是，你知道，也要保持良好的人脉，对吧？例如，如果你开始成为世界上最优秀的JavaScript人才，那么，你会去寻找一些你认为在JavaScript方面很棒的人，然后你变得如此优秀，或者对这门语言了解得如此之多，以至于这些人
aren't really you know reading their posts let's say isn't informing you like we did a post on crypto we're going to release a show on cryptocurrency that will be out by the time you see this show hear this show and uh you know let's say you're going to get to the point if you're into cryptocurrency where that show is going to be boring to you right right and when that happens you got to find the person who can sort of inspire you the person who knows way more about cryptocurrency than patrick and i and eventually you'll know more than that person you got to you have to constantly be seeking out um that that advancement and as you do that you'll notice the community even if it's a global community, it gets smaller and smaller and smaller. And it also gets more intimate. And you'll start to build those
不再能通过阅读他们的文章来启发你了。比如我们做了一期关于加密货币的节目，在我们录制这期节目时，那期节目应该已经发布了。如果你对加密货币感兴趣，你会发现那期节目对你来说很无聊，对吧？当这种情况发生时，你必须找到能启发你的人，那个比帕特里克和我更了解加密货币的人。最终你会比那个人知道得更多，你必须不断寻求那种进步。当你这样做时，你会发现社区，即使是一个全球社区，也会变得越来越小。它也会变得更亲密。你将开始建立那些
relationships that ultimately will be bridges to new opportunities. Oh, yeah, definitely. And if you're in that level of that inner circle, I mean, you'll never be looking for a job because there's so few, right? And everyone, it's that weird thing where it takes another expert to recognize an expert. Like someone, like to the novice, someone who's like at the 80 percentile
最终会成为通往新机会桥梁的关系。哦，是的，绝对。如果你处于那个核心圈子，我的意思是，你永远不会找工作，因为人太少了，对吧？而且每个人，这很奇怪，需要另一个专家才能识别出专家。就像对新手来说，处于80百分位的人
and someone who's at the 99 percentile look the same. But to the person who's like up in the 90 percentile of something, they know, they're like, yeah, OK, this guy is like one percent better that, you know, like think think super marathon runners. Right. That understand the difference between like a couple of seconds in a marathon time. Like it's it's it's a huge deal. Right. So I think that's that's definitely definitely the case. And once you become become part of that inner circle it becomes extremely valuable so the very the anecdote i'll share about that is at work we
和处于99百分位的人看起来是一样的。但对于那些处于90百分位以上的人来说，他们知道，他们会说：“是的，好吧，这家伙比那个人好1%。”想想超级马拉松运动员。对吧？他们理解马拉松时间几秒钟的差异。这可是件大事。对吧？所以我认为这绝对是这样。一旦你成为那个核心圈子的一部分，它就变得非常有价值。我分享一个关于这个的轶事，在工作中我们
do c++ programming so we often ask candidates you know what is their experience with c++ and we have this joke that you know on a scale and we ask each other like you know on a scale of one to ten what would you rate yourself as far as like c++ experience a lot of people this is and it's not meant to be a trick question but it's very revealing yeah because anyone who's like out of college and rates himself above a five is almost guaranteed to be sort of never done much programming you know when you when you start talking to them and you ask it's very clear they've not done much programming um yeah yeah and so then so we all you know kind of compare our scores and most people and a lot of people i think are very knowledgeable in c++ will rate
做C++编程，所以我们经常问候选人，他们的C++经验如何。我们有个笑话，我们问彼此：“从1到10分，你会给自己的C++经验打几分？”很多人，这不是为了刁难，但非常能说明问题。是的，因为任何刚毕业的人如果给自己打分超过5分，几乎可以肯定他们没怎么写过程序。当你开始和他们交谈时，很明显他们没怎么写过程序。是的，所以我们都会比较分数。大多数人，我认为很多在C++方面知识渊博的人会给自己打
themselves like five six and they've been doing c++ programming five six seven years um and we were sort of talking like we don't think anyone would be a 10 you know maybe herb sutter uh would be like a nine you know people who you know write the standard template library are probably like an eight people who go to cpp con are like a seven people have been doing like 10 to 15 years like a six right like the scale is really strict but it's almost universal across everybody at work it's very consistent right and it's very clear as you're pointing out people who don't fit in and it's not like a mean thing but it just instantly reveals how long someone's been doing something no you just have to ask who's your
5分或6分，尽管他们已经做了五、六、七年的C++编程。我们当时在讨论，我们认为没人会是10分。也许赫伯·萨特（Herb Sutter）会是9分。那些编写标准模板库的人可能是8分。去参加CppCon的人是7分。做了10到15年的人是6分。这个标准真的很严格，但在工作中几乎每个人都通用。这非常一致。正如你指出的，那些不符合标准的人很明显，这并不是刻薄，但这瞬间揭示了某人做某事的时间长短。不，你只需要问：“谁是你最喜欢的作者？”如果不是斯科特·迈耶斯（Scott Meyers），那么你不可能超过5分。很有趣，我曾经非常沉迷于C++。其实很有趣，我刚开始做C++开发时，我以为自己是个高手。我以为我很厉害，直到我去了TopCoder。那是个新东西。但是，伙计，我进去了，我进了单人房间，我进了SRM（单人比赛），我甚至连简单的题目都解不出来，对吧？
favorite author and if it's not um scott myers then you know then you can't be more than a five it's funny i was i was real big into the c actually it's it's funny i when i was a big c++ developer when i started out and i I thought I was hotshot. I thought I was good until I went to TabCoder. It's kind of a new thing. But, man, I went into there, and I went into the single room. I went into the SRMs, the single room matches, and I was like, I can't even solve the easy problem, right?
所以我不得不学习STL。我不得不阅读，你知道，我的脑子里装满了《Effective C++》，可能读了10遍，还有《More Effective C++》、《Effective STL》，我把所有的STL里里外外都学了一遍，还有Boost库，所有这些我以前根本不知道的东西。我做了三四年C++开发，对这些一无所知，我只是在混日子，我还以为自己很厉害。在那次经历之后，伙计，我可以在C++面试中表现得极其出色，没人能比得上。我会进行C++面试，我有一份八页的C++试卷，从简单的问题开始，到中等，再到困难，再到非常困难。我发誓，当时在惠普工作时，人们来应聘，我当时是最糟糕的面试官，你绝对不想让我面试。我基本上是个混蛋，只是因为我太兴奋了。我的偶像是斯科特·迈耶斯。很有趣，事情变了。但我会有那份试卷，人们进来声称自己是C++大师，结果连第一页都过不了。我记得有一个人。
So I had to, like, learn STL. And I had to read, read you know and so then i'm you know my head is in i read effective c++ you know probably like 10 times more effective c++ effective stl i'm learning all the you know all of the stl inside and out the boost library right like all this stuff right that i had no idea i'd been doing c++ development for like three four years no idea about any of this stuff i was just getting by and i thought i was good right and then and then after that experience man could i ace a i could ace a c++ interview like like nobody's business at that point and and i would give c++ interviews and i had this like eight
我还记得他的名字，海彪（Hai Biao）。他全都答对了。我当时试图向我的招聘经理解释，我说：“看，你不需要再面试了，我们结束了，你直接雇佣这个人就行了。我保证，即使他是我见过最不善社交的人，你也必须雇佣他。你不明白。”他无法理解这个人有多重要和出色。但很有趣，这确实是真的，当你看到它时，比如人们使用的语言，
page c++ and it would start off at easy questions and it'd go to medium and it'd go to hard and go to very hard and and i swear people would would apply for jobs i was working at hp at the time and i was i was you know i was the worst you would never want to interview me at hp i was a i was a dick basically just like just because i'm so excited about you know i mean i mean you? I was Scott Myers with my idol. It's funny how things have changed. But I would have this, you know, like APA. And people would come in and they'd profess to be these C++ gurus, and they wouldn't make it past page one. And so, you know, there was – I remember this one guy.
以及那种只有圈内人才能识别的核心圈子。是的，有一个概念，我想不起来那四个级别了，但我会试着拼凑一下。有“无意识的无知”，你根本不知道自己不知道什么。然后是你真正想要的，最难的一步是从“无意识的无知”到“有意识的无知”。正如你所说，比如TopCoder的例子，就是去TopCoder，意识到“哇，原来有这样一个世界”。因为一旦你迈出那一步，那就是你可以开始建立垫脚石的地方。那就是你可以获得那种带你走向“有意识的知识”的梯度的地方。然后最终达到“无意识的知识”，这又回到了原点，你甚至不需要思考它。它就在你的潜意识里。
I still remember his name, Hai Biao. And he, like, he got it all. And I was just like – I was trying to explain to my hiring manager i was like look you don't need to do this we're done you just hire this guy like i guarantee i don't even care if he's the most socially retarded person i've you've ever seen in your life you have to hire this guy like you don't understand and like he just he couldn't grasp how how important and phenomenal it is but it's funny like i mean it took it it it's it's so true like you know it when you when you see it like the kind of the things that people say the language
它自然而然地发生了。嗯，回到你我之间的联系，2004年，我是TopCoder的第30名。所以我排名30。杰森，这和你关于挣扎的故事无关。我只是告诉你，我几年前，大约18个月前，去过TopCoder，我表现得太差了。现实情况是，已经过去快十年了。距离我在TopCoder达到巅峰已经过去十多年了。我转向了其他技能。我转向了构建让我感兴趣的东西，把碎片拼凑在一起，我仍然做，我实际上转向了更多的统计学和数学，远离了算法和数据结构。自行车生锈了，对吧？但我没有失去的是
that they use and and it's that inner circle that uh that you can recognize within each other you know yeah there's this idea of uh i think it's i can't remember the four levels but i'll try to kind of piece it together but there's you, unconscious ignorance where you don't really know what you don't know. And then what you really want, the hardest step is that step from unconscious to conscience ignorance. As you said, like in the case of Topcoder, it's that going on Topcoder, realizing, whoa, there's this whole world. Because once you get to that step, that's where you can start the stepping stones. That's where you can kind of get that sort of gradient that takes you to conscious knowledge. And then eventually to unconscious knowledge, which is kind of circling all the way back to where you don't even really have to think about it. It's just in your unconscious.
人脉。很多TopCoder的顶尖高手，我都很了解他们。我和他们保持联系。我们偶尔会出去聚聚。这就是那种永久的东西。获得技能仍然超级重要，但在此过程中，利用那些几乎免费的机会去结识人。因为归根结底，那是永远不会消失的东西，或者非常容易找回来的东西。发封邮件说“好久不见”很容易，但要回到TopCoder的红色目标排名要难得多。相信我，几乎是不可能的。伙计，那太酷了。我没和多少真正做过TopCoder的人聊过，你是第30名，那太令人印象深刻了。没做过的人不知道那是一个多么了不起的成就。那确实是通过，顺便说一下，那确实是通过难以置信的努力。我们过去常常练习，我想大约每周40或50小时。是的，我们做到了。所以我的大学有编程竞赛团队，如果你加入，
It just happens naturally. Um, but getting back to the connections that you, I, um, in, uh, 2004, I was the 30th person on top coder. So I was ranked 30 and, and, uh, Jason does not relate to your story about struggling through this. I'm just telling you, I went, I went on, uh, I went on top coder a couple of years ago or about 18 months ago, and I was just terrible. And the reality is, you know, it's been, you know, what, I guess almost a decade. It's been over a decade since I was sort of at my sort of peak on Topcoder. And I moved on to sort of other skills. I moved on to sort of you know building things that entertain me and sort of kind of putting
你必须承诺每周练习40或50小时。这需要大量的努力。如果你不这样做，就像试图成为任何领域的专家一样，在某种程度上，它需要非凡的维护。但只要有足够的努力，特别是在这样一个领域，任何人都能取得巨大的进步。是的，我认为这也是成熟的标志，选择你不必在每件事上都做到最好。所以说，我们开玩笑说C++技能，但我认为人们打5分或6分，拿着高薪写C++代码是完全没问题的。没关系。你不必是8分、9分。
pieces together and less you know I still do I actually moved on to a lot more kind of statistics and math and away from like the algorithms and data structures and it just you know the bike got rusty right and but the thing I didn't lose was again
我认为成熟的标志是意识到这一点，超越它，并意识到有些事情在当时可能不值得付出努力。嗯，在你忘记之前，我想推荐一本好书叫《Peak》（刻意练习）。这是一本关于刻意练习的好书，它谈到了这样一个观点：本质上，所有这些，忘记马尔科姆·格拉德威尔（Malcolm Gladwell）说的吧。他不准确，但写《Peak》的那个人实际上是提出“10,000小时”概念的人，马尔科姆·格拉德威尔借用并误用了它。不幸的是，我不是马尔科姆·格拉德威尔的粉丝，因为我相信这是技能，因为我相信这是练习。那本书《Peak》真的谈到了这一点，他有研究证明这一点，并展示了为什么它是最重要的，而不是智力，不是智商，不是
the connections like a lot of the top, top coder people, I know them pretty well. I stay in contact with them. We go out every now and then. And, and, and that's the thing that's, that's kind of permanent. Like it's, it's still super important to get, to get the skills, but, you know, along the way, take the free, almost free opportunity to also connect with the people. Um, because, you know, ultimately that's the thing that, that, uh, that either it never goes away or it's very
任何其他东西，不是天赋或才华，是练习让一个人处于更高的水平。嗯，是的，另一件事，不要跳跃太多，回到财务问题上，我在职业生涯中见过很多人，我会认为他们已经退休了。有些人是因为家庭，有些人是因为环境，有些人是因为他们是真正的摇滚明星。我注意到他们大多数人的一点是，他们仍然在工作。工作可能会有所改变，但你真的看不到那种刻板印象，比如“我要中彩票”，或者这可能是一个糟糕的例子，但你，你知道，做某种财务
easy to bring it back. Like it's very easy to send an email and say, Hey, a long time, no C it's, it's much harder to get back into the, uh, you know, red target rank at top coder. Trust me, it's almost impossible. man that's cool yeah i i don't talk to many people that have actually actually done top coder that you're a number 30 that's that's pretty impressive that like people that haven't done this don't realize how amazing of an achievement that is it's and that was through By the way, that was through just again, just unbelievable effort. Like basically we used to I used to practice. I don't I think it was something like 40 or 50 hours a week. Yeah. And that and we did that. So so my university has this has this programming competition kind of programming team kind of a thing at the university and if you join you
状况，然后去夏威夷什么都不做。现实情况是，可能有一些人，他们设定了所有的愿景和努力，一切都只是为了财务，但我注意到大多数把自己归入“退休”类别的人，意味着他们只是为了好玩。这些人是那些拥有那种不可思议的激情的人，那里有巨大的惯性。我见过那些可以随时离开工作的人，他们留下来只是因为他们热爱它。做你不热爱的事情，多年来一无所获，这很难。抱歉，做你不热爱的事情，多年来一无所获，并坚持下去，这很难。对吧？但如果是你热爱的事情，并且你对你想去的地方有愿景，那并不真正依赖于
you have to commit to practicing for about 40 or 50 hours a week and uh it's just it's just a a ton of effort um but uh and it's the kind of thing where if you don't uh it's just like being you know uh trying to trying to be an expert in anything if you uh at some level it requires like extraordinary maintenance um but uh uh but yeah i mean with the right amount of effort um especially in a field like this like there uh anybody can can make like enormous progress yeah i think that's also a sign of maturity is choosing that you don't have to be the best at everything. So saying like, you know, we're joking about the C++ skill, but I don't think it's perfectly fine for people to be a five or six and be paid a lot of money to write C++ code. It's OK. You don't have to be eight, nine, you know.
任何人，那么你就可以继续取得进步。你可以在脑海中建立这个模型，并不断变得越来越好。这就是没有限制的地方，因为你在和自己竞争。我注意到那些人往往做得很好。哦，是的。你说到夏威夷的事情很有趣。从很小的时候起，我的人生目标之一就是早点退休。我19岁时就开始做房地产投资。
And I think that's a sign of maturity is realizing, getting past that and realizing like some things just may not be worth the effort at that time. Well, and you know, before I forget, a real good book I want to recommend is called Peak. It's a really good book on deliberate practice and it talks about the idea that you're, that essentially like all of this, all of the, forget what Malcolm Gladwell said. He's not accurate but but the guy that wrote peak is actually the guy that came up with the 10 000 hour uh concept that interesting malcolm gladwell borrowed and misused unfortunately i'm not a big malcolm gladwell we couldn't tell because i believe that it's skilled because i believe it is practice and that book peak like is really it really talks about and he has the studies to prove it and shows why that it is more than anything else not intelligence not iq not
我不想假装我当时有计划。我只是不想付房租。但后来我确实制定了一个计划。我花了很多钱。我的意思是，我睡在地板上的床垫上。我为这个目标付出了很多努力。这就是我的梦想。我想早点退休，这样我就可以做任何我想做的事。所以在我的脑海里，我想，我整天玩电子游戏。
anything else not natural ability or talent it's practice that that makes someone at the higher level at the highest levels right um yeah the other thing not to like to jump around too much, but getting back to the financial thing, I've met a lot of people in my career who I would consider retired. Some people because of their family, some people because of circumstances, and some people because they are just total rock stars. And the thing I noticed about most of them is they're still working. and some people because they are just total rock stars. And the thing I noticed about most of them is they're still working. And working might be a little, it might change, but you don't really see people, this sort of stereotypical, like I'm going to win the lottery, or maybe that's a bad example, but I'm you know uh you know do some kind of uh financial
这会很棒。对吧？我要去海滩生活。所有这些，我想要我的时间。所以大约四年前，我想是四、五年前。不，四年前。四年前，我实现了它。我做到了。
situation and then i'm going to go to hawaii and do nothing and the reality is you know there might be some people out there who they set their whole vision and all their effort and everything is just financial but the majority of people i noticed who put themselves in what I would call the retirement category, which means that they're just kind of there for fun. Those are the people who sort of had that incredible passion and there's massive inertia there. Like the kind of people I've met who can just leave their job at any time are the same people who are there just because they love it. Like it's, it's very hard to do something you love and get nothing out of it for years. Um, um, uh, sorry, it's very hard to do something you don't love and get nothing out of it for years and keep that going. Right. But if it's something you love, uh, and you have sort of, you know, uh, a vision for where you want to be, that doesn't really depend
在接近目标时，我开始有，当我能看到最终目标时，我想：“我将能够辞掉工作，我将终生拥有被动收入。”你知道吗？我想要每月1万的被动收入。所以不仅仅是住在某个小屋里。对吧？所以这是一种不错的生活方式。我快要接近那个目标了，我开始有这种恐慌，这种恐慌，比如“我该做什么？”我的计划是，我做到了，我辞掉了工作，我去了毛伊岛。哦，你真的做到了？我做到了，我那样做了大约两个月。
on anybody else, then you can continue to make progress. And you can sort of build this model in your mind, and continue to get better and better. And that's where sort of there's really no limit, because you're kind of, you're competing with yourself. And those are the people I notice who tend to do really well. Oh yeah. It's funny that you should say that, the Hawaii thing especially. From a young age, one of my goals in life was I wanted to retire young. I started doing real estate investment when I was 19.
当我回来时，我想：“不，我不能。”我非常担心永远待在那里。我说：“不，我不能，我不能这样做。我不需要工作。”所以我的“退休”定义不是坐在门廊上，或者整天冲浪，而是如果你不想做，你就不必做任何事，但这并不意味着你不会选择去做。这就是我带着重新燃起的使命感回来时所想的，我真的必须进行一些深刻的思考。如果你在生活中达到那个点，大多数人忙于生活，以至于他们从未真正思考过生活。
I don't want to pretend like I had a plan then. I just didn't want to pay rent. But later I did develop a plan. And I spent a lot. I mean, I slept on mattresses on the floor. I mean, I put a lot of effort into this goal. Like this was my dream. I wanted to retire young in life so that I could do whatever I wanted. So in my mind, I was like, I just play video games all day.
当你达到那个点时，这里有一个很好的练习，如果你想思考一下，这需要一些冥想。想象一下，如果你明天醒来银行里有5亿美元，你会做什么？花点时间冥想这个问题，因为你最初想到的答案大多是实际上能让你赚钱的事情。我用这么大的数字，比如5亿美元，是因为建立企业没有意义。你列出一长串清单。如果你完成这个练习，你就会开始排除一些东西，因为当你走到最后时，你会说：“哦，哇，是的，那会赚钱，但我不需要钱。”
This will be awesome. Right. I'm going to go live on the beach. All this stuff, I want my time. And so about four, I guess it's been four, five, four years, five years ago, about. No, four years ago. Four years ago, I hit it. I did it.
这会很棒。对。我要去海滩生活。所有这些东西，我想要属于我自己的时间。大概四年前，我想应该是四、五年前吧。不，四年前。四年前，我实现了它。我做到了。
And coming up to it, I started to have like, when I was like, when I could see the goal, the end goal on site, I was like, I'm going to be able to quit my job and I'm going to have passive income for the rest of my life. You know? And I wanted to have like 10 K a month of passive income. So it's not like just living in a hut somewhere. Right. So it was like a decent lifestyle. And so I, I was coming close to that and I started to have these, like these, these, this kind of panic these panels like well what am I gonna do right and and my plan was and I did it I went I I quit my job I went to Maui okay oh you actually did it I did and I and I did that for about two months
在临近目标时，我开始有种感觉，当我能看到最终目标时，我就想，我终于可以辞职了，余生都能有被动收入。你知道吗？我想要每月一万美元的被动收入。所以这不仅仅是住在某个茅屋里。对吧。这是一种体面的生活方式。当我快要达到那个目标时，我开始感到恐慌，心想我该做什么呢？我的计划是，我也确实这么做了，我辞了职，去了茂宜岛。哦，你真的去了？是的，我去了，我在那里待了大约两个月。
and I when I came back I was like no I can't like I was strongly concerned just staying there forever you know and I was like no I can't I can't do this I like I don't need to work right so my definition of retired is is is is not like sitting on the porch or you know just surfing all day it's like you don't have to do anything if you don't want to but but you it doesn't mean you don't choose to and and that's what I came's when I came back with my renewed mission and I kind of really had to do some really deep thinking. If you ever get to that point in life, most people are so busy living life that they never really think about life.
当我回来时，我心想，不，我不能一直待在那里。我非常担心一直待在那里。我心想，不，我做不到。我不需要工作。所以，我对退休的定义不是坐在门廊上，或者整天冲浪，而是如果你不想做，你就不必做任何事，但这并不意味着你不能选择去做。这就是我带着重新燃起的使命感回来后的感悟，我不得不进行非常深刻的思考。如果你的人生达到了那个阶段，大多数人忙于生活，以至于从未真正思考过生活。
When you get to that point, and here's a good exercise if you ever want to just think about, and it takes some meditation on this, But imagine if you woke up with $500 million in the bank tomorrow, what would you do? Spend some time meditating on the question because most of the answers that you first come up with are things that actually are things that would make you money. I use a big number like that, like $500 million, because it doesn't make sense to build a business. You go through a whole list. If you go through the exercise, you'll start to rule stuff out because as you go to the end of the line, you'll say, oh, wow, yeah, that would be to make money, but I don't need any money.
当你达到那个阶段时，这里有一个很好的练习，如果你想思考一下的话，这需要一些冥想。想象一下，如果明天醒来时你的银行账户里有五亿美元，你会做什么？花点时间冥想这个问题，因为你最初想到的答案大多是那些能让你赚钱的事情。我用五亿美元这么大的数字，是因为再建立一家企业已经没有意义了。你会列出一长串清单。如果你完成了这个练习，你就会开始排除一些事情，因为当你思考到最后，你会说，哦，哇，是的，那是为了赚钱，但我根本不需要钱。
It's kind of a scary process. But I had to really do some deep thinking, and that's where I'm at. With Simple Programmer now, Yes, I make money. Yes, I still make profit from the best version of myself, about pushing my limits, about reaching my full potential. And it's something that I'll never reach the end of, right? So I don't have this problem anymore, but now it's like, how can I best utilize the time that I have to really maximize whatever potential that I could achieve during this time, not for an end goal, not so I can make so much money, not so I could play video games all
这确实是一个有点可怕的过程。但我不得不进行深刻的思考，这就是我现在的处境。对于现在的Simple Programmer，是的，我赚钱。是的，我仍然从最好的自我中获利，关于突破极限，关于发挥我的全部潜能。这是我永远无法达到终点的事情，对吧？所以我不再有这个问题了，但现在的问题是，我该如何最好地利用我拥有的时间，真正最大化我在这段时间内所能实现的任何潜能，不是为了一个最终目标，不是为了赚很多钱，也不是为了让我整天玩电子游戏。
day. I have all those options, but it has a different purpose. It's really hard to describe, but it's funny that you said that about going to Hawaii because that was exactly my thinking and my scenario. And people all the time when I tell a story on my YouTube channel, they're like, oh, you're crazy. If I win the lottery, I'm like, no. The worst thing that could possibly happen to you is to come into an infusion of cash. It would ruin your life.
我有所有这些选择，但它有不同的目的。这真的很难描述，但有趣的是你提到了去夏威夷，因为那正是我的想法和情景。当我经常在我的YouTube频道上讲故事时，人们总是说，哦，你疯了。如果我中了彩票，我会说，不。你可能发生的最糟糕的事情就是突然得到一笔巨款。这会毁了你的生活。
It would ruin your character. It would just ruin everything because everything you're dreaming for, everything you're aiming for, which suddenly you'd have it, and then you'd lose purpose and when you lose purpose you know everything it's horrible so it's just interesting yeah this is a good thought exercise for people who who want to understand this is get it get your favorite video game right and then go online and find the way to sort of cheat in that game like let's say let's take grand theft auto let's say you're a huge grand theft auto now now they have the version online which i don't know much about but i assume you can't really cheat on the internet but let's take grand theft auto 3 um let's say you're that's your favorite game you spent all the time
这会毁了你的人格。这会毁了一切，因为你梦寐以求的一切，你追求的一切，突然间你都有了，然后你就会失去目标，当你失去目标时，你知道一切都很糟糕，所以这很有趣，是的，这是一个很好的思想练习，对于那些想要理解这一点的人来说，就是拿你最喜欢的电子游戏，然后上网找到在那个游戏中作弊的方法，比如，让我们以《侠盗猎车手》为例，假设你是一个超级《侠盗猎车手》迷，现在他们有了在线版本，我不太了解，但我假设你不能在互联网上真正作弊，但让我们以《侠盗猎车手3》为例，嗯，假设那是你最喜欢的游戏，你花了很多时间
unlocking the t-shirts and getting all the cars and stuff now go in that game start over and and and use the cheat code which gives you like infinite money and the ability to fly right like superman right and see how long you'll play that game i guarantee you it won't be more than a week right like it's it's going to be amazing you can fly you could drop helicopters from the sky or something but after a week it's done it actually kind of killed the sort of narrative and the novelty and the experience of that game right and and and i would imagine winning the lottery is kind of like doing that to your life right like uh it's sort of it it doesn't really kind of it all of a sudden just throws all of your kind of goals and your values kind of out of whack exactly yep i i totally agree that's a great comparison that is it's so true
解锁T恤，获得所有汽车之类的东西，现在进入那个游戏，重新开始，并使用作弊码，给你无限的金钱和飞行的能力，就像超人一样，看看你能玩那个游戏多久，我保证你玩不到一周，对吧，就像它会很神奇，你可以飞，你可以从天上扔直升机之类的东西，但一周后，它就结束了，它实际上有点扼杀了那种叙事、新奇感和游戏体验，对吧，而且我想象中，中彩票就像对你的生活做那样的事情，对吧，它有点，它突然间把你所有的目标和价值观都搞乱了，完全正确，是的，我完全同意，这是一个很好的比较，这太真实了。
right yeah it's funny i'm playing like a breath i'm playing the zelda breath of the wild game and i'm like i am not looking on the internet for anything there's some stuff i'm like i don't understand how these recipes work and stuff and and i'm like no no because as soon as i look up anything it will ruin the entire game for me i just want to figure it all out and discover it myself yeah i'm exactly the same boat i played uh final fantasy 7 which is one of the considered one of the best video games of all time and i played it you know a very long time ago. And I'd beaten, I'd completed Final Fantasy, I think, four and six and two. I don't remember.
对，是的，很有趣，我正在玩《塞尔达传说：旷野之息》，我没有在网上查找任何东西，有些东西我不明白这些食谱是如何工作的，但我说不，不，因为一旦我查了任何东西，它就会毁了整个游戏，我只想自己弄清楚并发现它，是的，我和你完全一样，我玩过《最终幻想7》，它被认为是史上最好的电子游戏之一，我很久以前玩过它。而且我通关了，我完成了《最终幻想》，我想是四代、六代和二代。我不记得了。
This was all a long time ago. But I was playing through seven and I wasn't even stuck. I was just, there was one part where it was a little bit open-ended. You can kind of go to different towns. It wasn't exactly clear what to do next. And instead of kind of exploring,
那都是很久以前的事了。但我正在玩第七代，我甚至没有卡住。我只是，有一个部分有点开放式。你可以去不同的城镇。下一步该做什么并不完全清楚。而不是探索，
I thought, oh, let me go on the internet and just see and once i went on the internet i realized oh i i missed this part back here and i can never go back and get it and it's done and it actually just killed the whole game like oh yeah like i realized like i i kind of you stare into the mirror and the mirror stares back at you or whatever it was just uh i just it literally killed the game for me and i haven't been able to i haven't played it since um and yes it's it's the same kind of thing uh um it's actually kind of a little dangerous to do that oh yeah yeah it's funny i mean i this is my philosophy in life and again a lot of people doubt doubt it on youtube but all the time i get i get people because there's all you know i my my
我想，哦，让我上网看看，一旦我上网，我就意识到，哦，我错过了后面的这一部分，我再也回不去拿它了，它结束了，它实际上扼杀了整个游戏，就像，哦，是的，就像我意识到，我盯着镜子，镜子也盯着我，或者无论是什么，它真的扼杀了游戏，我从那以后就没玩过它，嗯，是的，这是同样的事情，嗯，这样做实际上有点危险，哦，是的，是的，这很有趣，我的意思是，这是我的人生哲学，同样，很多人在YouTube上怀疑它，但我一直被指责，因为你知道，我的
youtube channel is kind of a fitness youtube channel as well right because i do a lot of a lot of stuff and so all the time i get accused of being on steroids and i'm like i can't like there's nothing i go like i mean tests or whatever i can't prove that i'm not on steroids but what i could tell you this is that if you listen to any of my videos in my life philosophy you would know that i would never take a shortcut because i'm not about the end result i'm about who i become the process right and it's and it's like it's so hard to communicate this point to to people that are as much as i argue this point or like so many people are still like no i would still want to win the lottery it would still be awesome i would give the money to my family. And like, no, you like anything that you achieve that, that you haven't earned. Right. It's like
YouTube频道也是一个健身YouTube频道，对吧，因为我做了很多事情，所以我一直被指责使用类固醇，我说我不能，没有什么，我去做测试之类的，我无法证明我没有使用类固醇，但我可以告诉你的是，如果你听过我的任何视频和人生哲学，你就会知道我永远不会走捷径，因为我不在乎最终结果，我在乎我成为了什么样的人，这个过程，对吧，而且向人们传达这一点太难了，尽管我争论这个观点，但很多人仍然说，不，我还是想中彩票，那还是很棒，我会把钱给我的家人。而且，不，你获得的任何你没有赚到的东西。对。就像
the, I, I get, I'll get flack for this, but I'll say it anyway. Cause I, I, is it, I, you know, I do, I run like 40 miles a week and I ran a marathon like a couple of weeks ago. And there's people that will sign up for the marathon and they'll walk and i mean if you're 90 that's fine but if you're like a capable human being and you're just walking a marathon in order to get a medal i'm sorry like i i don't have a problem like like that that's fine like i'm not saying it because like i'm judging you as a person i'm just saying you are jipping yourself like like how how much when you put that when i put the medal i've got a rack you guys can't see it here but i've got my medals for my half marathons and my marathons and my marathon medal to me like when i look at that means something right i can look at that and i'm like
我，我，我会因此受到抨击，但我还是会说。因为我，我，你知道，我确实，我每周跑40英里，几周前我跑了一场马拉松。有些人会报名参加马拉松，然后他们会走，我的意思是如果你90岁了那没关系，但如果你是一个有能力的人，你只是为了得到奖牌而走完马拉松，我很抱歉，我没有问题，那没关系，我不是因为评判你个人才这么说，我只是说你在欺骗自己，当我把奖牌挂在架子上时，你们在这里看不到，但我有我的半程马拉松和全程马拉松的奖牌，对我来说，当我看着它时，它意味着什么，对吧，我可以看着它，我想
man that like that was four and a half hours it wasn't just four and a half hours it was like weeks and you know months worth of work and effort and blood and sweat and tears. If you are like this overweight person who signs up for a marathon and walks it and didn't do any training and you get the medal and you put that on your wall, what is it? It's just to show other people. It doesn't mean anything to you. You know what I mean? That's my whole – that's the whole thing. It's so hard to communicate that concept to people.
伙计，那是四个半小时，不仅仅是四个半小时，那是几周甚至几个月的工作、努力、血汗和泪水。如果你是一个超重的人，报名参加马拉松，走完全程，没有进行任何训练，你得到了奖牌并把它挂在墙上，那是什么？那只是为了向别人炫耀。它对你没有任何意义。你知道我的意思吗？这就是我的全部——这就是全部。向人们传达这个概念太难了。
It's the same people that say, I want to win the lottery or i just want the six-figure job i don't care if i actually know the programming you know i just want someone to i just want to get lucky and get the job and it's like it's all those things it's like if you haven't earned it yeah it might be fun to fly around in the video game like you said but it's going to be so meaningless and empty to you that uh that you you you start to think that all of life is like that. And you, you, you forget that, that, you know, that the meaningful things in life are the things that you actually, you know, it's that, it's that money you put together to, that you earn mowing lawns to, to buy that bicycle. That's what, what makes it all, everything in life valuable. And
同样的人说，我想中彩票，或者我只是想要一份六位数的薪水，我不在乎我是否真的懂编程，你知道，我只是想让某人，我只是想走运得到这份工作，就像所有这些事情，如果你没有赚到它，是的，在电子游戏中飞来飞去可能很有趣，就像你说的，但它对你来说将是毫无意义和空虚的，以至于你开始认为生活就是这样。而且你忘记了，你知道，生活中最有意义的事情是你真正，你知道，那是你割草赚来的钱，去买那辆自行车。这就是让生活中一切变得有价值的东西。而且
it's so easy to get disconnected from that. I mean, we've, I've been guilty of it. We've all been guilty of it, but it's, it's so hard to communicate across that chasm, I find. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah. Oh, go ahead, Patrick. No, I was going to say, so I'm not much of a quote person, but my quote is Warren Buffett saying that his goal was not to leave his kids enough money to do nothing, but just enough to do anything. Oh, I got it backwards. I think the goal is to leave your kids enough money to do nothing but just enough to do anything oh i got the backwards i think the goal is to leave your kids enough money to do anything but not so much that they can do nothing yeah it's sort of the same philosophy yeah like your point is to be able to do enough that you open doors not so much that you can just sit around and do nothing that's really boring the analogy was if you were on um the notch who invented minecraft and you followed his twitter
很容易与此脱节。我的意思是，我也有过错。我们都有过错，但我发现，跨越那道鸿沟进行交流太难了。是的，这很有道理。是的。哦，请继续，帕特里克。不，我想说的是，我不是一个喜欢引用名言的人，但我的名言是沃伦·巴菲特说的，他的目标不是给孩子们留下足够的钱让他们什么都不做，而是刚好足够让他们做任何事。哦，我记反了。我想目标是给你的孩子留下足够的钱让他们什么都不做，但刚好足够让他们做任何事，哦，我记反了，我想目标是给你的孩子留下足够的钱让他们做任何事，但不要多到让他们什么都不做，是的，这是一种哲学，是的，你的观点是能够做足够多的事情来打开大门，而不是多到你可以坐着什么都不做，那真的很无聊。这个类比是，如果你在，嗯，发明《我的世界》的Notch，你关注了他的推特
feed right around the time like microsoft bought out minecraft oh yeah yeah i don't know how many people did this and i don't know i was following him even before that and yeah i won't spoil your story but yeah i heard no it's okay but yeah i feel like a little bit this happened to him like he had other games that he was in the process now he suddenly i mean he already didn't need to work but he still was but to get sort of that major payout he bought a really big house he could pretty much do anything he wanted and i mean i i didn't kind of keep following him but he basically had a little bit of like a meltdown like he kind of lost lost direction oh yeah yeah i mean he was posting you know i mean you can you guys can look you folks can look it up but basically things like you know i have mean, you folks can look it up, but basically things like, you know, I have nothing in my life.
动态，就在微软收购《我的世界》的时候，哦，是的，是的，我不知道有多少人这样做，我甚至在那之前就关注他了，是的，我不会剧透你的故事，但是的，我听到了，不，没关系，但是的，我觉得这发生在他身上，他还有其他正在进行的游戏，现在他突然，我的意思是，他已经不需要工作了，但他仍然在工作，但为了获得那种主要的报酬，他买了一栋非常大的房子，他几乎可以做任何他想做的事，我的意思是，我没有一直关注他，但他基本上有点崩溃，他有点失去了方向，哦，是的，是的，我的意思是，他发布了，你知道，我的意思是，你们可以查一下，但基本上是这样的，你知道，我
The people who worked in my company feel like I sold them out. I have no friends, stuff like that. And it's kind of sad, you know. Oh, yeah. And the nasty thing about it, being in that situation, is not only did he honestly feel that way people doubted his sincerity and then they were upset at him because he was expressing these these feelings and saying you have no right to have these feelings because if i were in your situation i would be happy and that that is just i mean that's going to make him feel even worse but i mean it's it's a human condition and and so like if you don't
我的生活中一无所有。在我公司工作的人觉得我出卖了他们。我没有朋友，诸如此类。这有点可悲，你知道。哦，是的。而且在这种情况下，最糟糕的事情是，他不仅真诚地有这种感觉，人们还怀疑他的真诚，然后他们对他感到不满，因为他在表达这些感受，并说你没有权利有这些感受，因为如果我在你的处境中，我会很高兴，这简直是，我的意思是，这会让他感觉更糟，但我的意思是，这是人类的状况，所以如果你不
figure out how to deal with this right like this is one of those things like I tell people all the time. Well, you know, but like I had to face this. Like you said, looking into the abyss and the abyss stared back at me. Yeah, that I had to face this. And I'm telling you, and he definitely had to face this. But like you got to think about this ahead of time and really figure out your life, because if your life is just about hitting some number, hitting some goals, man, you're setting yourself up for such a... How many rock stars, how many people that come into fame or end up making a lot of money or becoming super famous people, how many of them end up committing suicide or getting into just like their whole life becomes drugs
弄清楚如何处理这个问题，对吧，这是我一直告诉人们的事情之一。嗯，你知道，但我不得不面对这个。就像你说的，凝视深渊，深渊也凝视着我。是的，我不得不面对这个。我告诉你，他肯定不得不面对这个。但你必须提前考虑这一点，真正弄清楚你的生活，因为如果你的生活只是为了达到某个数字，达到某些目标，伙计，你是在为自己设置一个……有多少摇滚明星，有多少成名或最终赚了很多钱或成为超级名人的人，他们中有多少人最终自杀或陷入了他们的整个生活变成了毒品
because they're hugely depressed? This is not just because they're defective people that don't know how to handle fame or money. It's because this is what most people will be like if they haven't actually thought about this and haven't really figured out how to live a purposeful life that is not just driven based on some goal, right? To tie it back into the systems versus goals from the beginning but yeah definitely cool well yeah we could obviously we could talk about this forever i think it's fascinating hopefully maybe we'll have you back later on like sometime in the future um but uh yeah this was awesome so if uh is there anything actually i think you you kind of alluded to it in the beginning there's a book that you have coming out pretty soon, right?
因为他们非常抑郁？这不仅仅是因为他们是有缺陷的人，不知道如何处理名声或金钱。这是因为如果大多数人没有真正思考过这个问题，没有真正弄清楚如何过一种不仅仅是由某个目标驱动的有目的的生活，他们就会变成这样，对吧？回到一开始的系统与目标，但是的，绝对很酷，好吧，是的，我们显然可以永远谈论这个，我认为这很迷人，希望也许我们以后会在未来让你回来，嗯，但是的，这太棒了，所以如果，有什么，其实我想你在开始时提到了，你有一本书很快就要出版了，对吧？
Yeah, let me, allow me to plug my book. That was your opening. There we go. So I do, I have a book. It should be out, assuming that, you know, July 19th is the launch date, assuming that those got around the same time. And it is called The Complete Software Developer's Career Guide. And it is a massive book.
是的，让我，允许我宣传一下我的书。那是你的开场白。好了。所以我确实有一本书。它应该会出版，假设，你知道，7月19日是发布日期，假设那些在同一时间左右。它叫《完整的软件开发人员职业指南》。这是一本厚重的书。
We're talking like, right now the estimated page count is 800 pages. Wow. And it is everything I know about software development from my 15-year career and everything that I have gathered from, I mean, I know, you know, I've hung out with a lot of industry experts. I won't do a bunch of name dropping here, but obviously, you know, with Simple Program on YouTube and everything, I coach
我们谈论的是，现在估计页数是800页。哇。这是我从15年的职业生涯中了解到的关于软件开发的一切，以及我从，我的意思是，我知道，你知道，我和很多行业专家在一起交流过。我不会在这里列举很多名字，但显然，你知道，有了YouTube上的Simple Programmer和一切，我指导
people and I've gathered a lot of career advice and wisdom over this time. And I've basically put it into what I'm calling the like my goal in creating this book was to make the book that every software developer should have on their bookshelf like no question about it and you know I spent a lot of a lot of time working on this it basically to give you a quick overview that it goes from it has everything from the very it's broken into five sections the first section is how to get started. If you don't know anything about software development, what language to learn, you know, should you go to college, boot camp, self-taught, how to learn a language. The second section is how to get a job, whether it be your first job or your experience, and
人们，我在这段时间里收集了很多职业建议和智慧。我基本上把它放进了我所说的，我写这本书的目标是让这本书成为每个软件开发人员书架上都应该有的书，毫无疑问，你知道，我花了很多很多时间在这上面，它基本上给你一个快速的概述，它从，它有从，它分为五个部分，第一部分是如何开始。如果你对软件开发一无所知，学习什么语言，你知道，你应该去上大学，训练营，自学，如何学习一门语言。第二部分是如何找工作，无论是你的第一份工作还是你的经验，以及
then how to negotiate your salary, how to like choose between contract or permanent employment, like all these kinds of stuff that no one really talks about that is really important and how to do a resume, all kinds of stuff related to that. And then the third section is all the stuff you need to know as a software developer. I gathered like all of the like CVS
然后是如何协商你的薪水，如何选择合同工还是永久雇佣，所有这些没人真正谈论但非常重要的事情，以及如何写简历，所有与此相关的事情。第三部分是作为软件开发人员你需要知道的所有事情。我收集了所有像CVS
and source control and continuous integration and what is web development versus backend development versus mobile, like all of that stuff. And then the fourth section is how to function, work as a software developer.
和源代码控制和持续集成，什么是Web开发与后端开发与移动开发，所有这些东西。第四部分是如何作为软件开发人员工作。
So this is stuff like how do you deal with your boss? How do you deal with your coworkers? How do you deal with discrimination or prejudice in the workspace? How do you dress for work? This is all targeted towards software developers. And then the fifth section is how to advance your career. So you've got all the other stuff down. What if you wanted to go and start speaking at conferences?
所以这些是，比如你如何处理你的老板？你如何处理你的同事？你如何处理工作场所的歧视或偏见？你如何穿着上班？这一切都是针对软件开发人员的。第五部分是如何提升你的职业生涯。所以你已经掌握了所有其他东西。如果你想去参加会议演讲怎么办？
What if you wanted to start a podcast? What if you wanted to go beyond and become a freelancer and bill a few hundred dollars an hour? How would you do this? And so the book is – that's why it's massive is because it tries to cover pretty much all of that uh at a pretty pretty in-depth level and so yeah it's going to be launching july 19th and i will be doing the kindle version of it for 99 cents for that day normally it'll be nine nine or normally be nine dollars and nine nine cents i'm not sure what i'm going to price the print version just but just because it's such a thick book, I have, I've got to get a quote. I'm working on getting it typeset right now. So I'm
如果你想开始播客怎么办？如果你想超越自我，成为一名自由职业者，每小时收费几百美元怎么办？你会怎么做？所以这本书——这就是为什么它很厚，因为它试图在相当深入的层面上涵盖所有这些，所以是的，它将在7月19日发布，我将在那天以99美分的价格提供Kindle版本，通常是9.99美元，我不确定我会给印刷版定什么价格，但仅仅因为它是一本这么厚的书，我必须得到一个报价。我正在努力排版。所以我
guessing it, it'll be heavily discounted on launch day as well. But, uh, but yeah, so it's, it's, you know, the goal for this launch, by the way, too, is to be the number one bestselling book on Amazon on that day, like across all categories. So what's the title one more time? The Complete Software Developer's Career Guide. And so actually, if you want to check it out, if you just go to simpleprogrammer.com forward slash career guide, that will be, it'll be the book landing page pre-launch. And then on the launch, it'll have like bonuses.
猜它在发布当天也会有很大的折扣。但是，是的，所以，你知道，顺便说一下，这次发布的目标是成为亚马逊当天所有类别中排名第一的畅销书。那么书名再重复一遍？《完整的软件开发人员职业指南》。所以实际上，如果你想看看它，如果你去simpleprogrammer.com斜杠career guide，那将是这本书的预发布页面。然后在发布时，它会有一些奖励。
I think we've got a package that we're putting together, like $150 bonus package of course material as well. That will all for 99 cents. So cool. And we'll have the link on the show notes as well for people. Awesome. Awesome. Cool.
我想我们有一个我们正在整理的套餐，比如150美元的课程材料奖励套餐。所有这些都只要99美分。太酷了。我们也会在节目笔记中提供链接。太棒了。太棒了。酷。
Well, thank you so much for being on the show. Looking forward to checking out that book um i'll definitely pick it up for 99 cents i i buy almost every humble bundle where you you spend a dollar and you get three games oh yeah that's like your limit a dollar yeah yeah well you could uh yeah anyways but uh but even even if if like no matter what i will spend a dollar i won't even look at the games if they when they send me the email matter what, I will spend a dollar. I won't even look at the games. When they send me the email for the new bundle, I spend a dollar. And sometimes I spend more if the other games look good.
好吧，非常感谢你参加节目。期待看看那本书，嗯，我肯定会以99美分买下它，我几乎买了每一个Humble Bundle，你花一美元就能得到三个游戏，哦，是的，那是你的极限，一美元，是的，是的，好吧，你可以，嗯，无论如何，但即使，无论如何，我都会花一美元，如果他们给我发电子邮件，我甚至不会看游戏，无论如何，我都会花一美元。我甚至不会看游戏。当他们给我发新捆绑包的电子邮件时，我花一美元。如果其他游戏看起来不错，有时我会花更多。
But, you know, I recently did this. I spent a dollar. I got this game. It had terrible reviews. And all the reviews kind of said, you know, look, the game looks beautiful, but the gameplay is kind of messed up. And the developers released this patch saying, oh, we made all these fixes, right? And I played it and it was amazing. And, you know, they just fixed the problems, you know, and they had just gotten a bad rap, right?
但是，你知道，我最近做了这个。我花了一美元。我得到了这个游戏。它的评价很糟糕。所有的评论都说，你知道，看，游戏看起来很漂亮，但游戏玩法有点乱。开发人员发布了这个补丁说，哦，我们做了所有这些修复，对吧？我玩了它，它太棒了。而且，你知道，他们只是修复了问题，你知道，他们只是名声不好，对吧？
The book that I tell everyone to read was Negotiating for Dummies. I got that for a dollar. And just it was one of these kind of flash sales. And so I'll definitely pick this up for a dollar and check it out. Cool. Well, I appreciate it. Yeah, hopefully, like I said, this has been crazy trying to put all this launch together and writing this book.
我告诉每个人要读的书是《谈判傻瓜指南》。我花了一美元买的。这只是那种闪购之一。所以我肯定会花一美元买下它看看。酷。好吧，我很感激。是的，希望，就像我说的，把所有这些发布和写这本书放在一起真是太疯狂了。
But I really want this to be a book that every developer can put on their bookshelf because I feel like it's been lacking like this, this kind of advice, you know, I put the book together cause I felt like I didn't want to write another book, trust me after writing my first book, but I just felt like I have to put this out there. So. Cool. Well, thank you. And simple uh, simple programmer.com is the site. We'll also have the link to, uh, in the show notes and all that.
但我真的希望这是一本每个开发人员都能放在书架上的书，因为我觉得它一直很缺乏，这种建议，你知道，我把这本书放在一起是因为我觉得我不想再写一本书了，相信我，写完我的第一本书后，但我只是觉得我必须把它发布出来。所以。酷。好吧，谢谢。Simple programmer.com是网站。我们也会在节目笔记中提供链接，诸如此类。
And, uh, thanks for coming on the show. Yeah. Thanks for having me guys. You guys are awesome. All right. Thanks.
而且，谢谢你来参加节目。是的，谢谢你们邀请我。你们太棒了。好的。谢谢。
Bye. Bye. All right. Take care. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。好的。保重。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行重混、改编，但你必须注明帕特里克和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子发表评论。